PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT-
BEFORE GETS ARE WE JUST WENT
FOR A FEW MORE MEMBERS TO. JOIN
US ONCE WE GET OUR AWESOME
MEMBERS UP TO A- THE DOCTOR
WILL GET GOING AND WITH THAT
SAID. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE
MEMBER COMING IN BUT I THINK-
MISTER CHARLES COMMITTEES
DOESN'T SHARP WOODEN START WITH
MR LOW BUT- WILL GIVE ANOTHER
MINORITY THANKS.
WELCOME TO THE
SOMEBODY COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT. THIS IS
THE ONLY HEARING THE WILL HOLD
ON THE SIMPLY BILLS UNLESS
THOSE THAT ARE RETURNED FROM
THE SENATE HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGES. FIRST ON THE START TO
THANK ALL THE STUFF THAT MADE
OUR RETURN TO THE CAPITAL TO
HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE THIS
INCLUDES STAFF FROM SOMEBODY
ROLES. THE SUMMARY SERGEANTS
AND THE LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER
WHO PUT IN COUNTLESS HOURS. PER
OCCURRING AND FOR GREEN THE NEW
EQUIPMENT ACT TECHNOLOGY WERE
ABLE TO USE TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTICIPATION
IN OUR HEARINGS. ALSO LIKE TO
THANK COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE BEEN
TIRES THE WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT THE BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE CONTINUES DURING
THESE TIMES. TO THAT END I WANT
TO SHARE A FEW NOTES ABOUT THE
LOGISTICS OF OUR HEARING TODAY.
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
SERVE THE SAFETY. OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY AND ENSURE THE
PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. DUE TO THE CURRENT
STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AT
ABOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO
WHERE ARE THE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHED AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING. IN PERSON WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FIRST
FOR PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM. WHICH
IS ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN THE
STATE CAPITAL WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICAL DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE SEVEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WHICH IS A
NUMBER OF ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO MEMBERS AT A TIME
HER PRESENTING THEIR BILLS
BEFORE US. A MINIMAL CONTINUE
OF STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER
OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE
CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL. AND FOR
THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILLS PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND. NOW ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE WHEN THE BILL'S
BEEN CALLED. I ALSO SAID YOU
HAVEN'T. THAT IF YOU ARE
PRESIDENT ROOM PLEASE DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONES. YOU CAN
EXIT THE ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED. TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. SECOND FOR
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE WITNESSES.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TELL AS FAR FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM. WE HAVE SOME BILL
WHAT BILL WITNESSES. MAKING USE
OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO THAT MEMBERS CAN
WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY. LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM
AND ALSO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
WITNESSES. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY FOR STREAM FROM
THE WITNESSES VIDEO CUMBERSOME
SO PLEASE BE PATIENT. NEXT FOR
THE WITNESSES CALLING VIA PHONE
WILL ALSO BE USING. A MODERATED
PHONE. SERVICE DROUGHT WHICH
ANY WITNESSES CONTEST FROM THE
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN AREA CODE SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER N
THE ARE COMMITTEES WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO. SO
WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL HAS
BEEN CAUGHT PRESIDENT AND THE
BILL BY THE COMMITTEE. THE
OPERATE ON THE LINE AND WE'LL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE RELEASED. IN THE QUEUE BASED
ON WHETHER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEDIUM YOUR LIFE CAN BROADCAST.
IN YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU
ARE THE MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR A FOR OR AGAINST
THE BILL YOUR REMAIN ON A-LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF ENTER YOUR CALL TO
SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATOR PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN. CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX AREA
CODE. THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. ALSO ONE OUT THERE WE ARE
ACCEPTING WITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGHOUT THE UP THE POSITION.
LETTER PORTAL LINK THAT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA OR WE ALSO BEING
MINE FOR NO RESPECT FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. SHOULD SOMEONE ON THE
MODERATED ONLINE NEED TO BE
MUTED DUE TO GOING OVER TIME OR
NOT A HEARING TO INSTRUCTIONS
OR IN A PROPER LANGUAGE. I WAS
A THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS WHICH WILL ALERT THE
EIGHTEEN ANTI MODERATOR TO MEET
THAT PERSON. WITH THAT SAID
LET'S GO TO THE GENDER. THERE
ARE FOURTEEN BILLS HERE ON THE
CHEN TODAY WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
THE CONTENT THEY ARE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB NINETEEN OH SIX
SALAS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY ONE OH ONE THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT. I'M FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN O'DONNELL. IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN PROVIDING
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF THESE
BILLS PLEASE ALL UP BILLS
PUBLIC COMMON IS NO LONGER
NECESSARY. UNLESS SOMEONE FROM
THE COMMITTEE DECIDES TO REMOVE
A BILL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BUT YOU CAN REGISTER
POSITION. THROUGH THAT ADVOCACY
POORLY ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISES
SUBSTITUTING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES TODAY WHO IS
ABSENT WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAILS. WE WILL START EACH BILL
WHAT THE AUTHOR PRESENTING WHEN
THE AUTHORS DONE MAKING THEIR
OPENING STATEMENT WILL GO TO
THE MAIN WITNESS WHO WERE
PRIVILEGED DEMO PREVIOUSLY
IDENTIFIED BY EACH AUTHOR SO
THAT EVERYONE IS WHERE EACH
BILL WILL ONLY HAVE TWO MAIN
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
MAIN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH ONE EACH OF THESE AND
THERE WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES
MAXIMUM TO PROVIDE THEIR
COMMENTS. AS A MAIN WITNESS IF
YOU EXCEED THOSE THREE MINUTES
I'LL ASK MODERATOR TO PLACE ON
MUTE. TO FAIRNESS TO EVERYONE
ELSE BUT ME WITNESSES SHOULD
REMAIN AVAILABLE. UNTIL THE
BILL HAS BEEN VOTED ON OR JUST
IN CASE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS AFTER
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE DONE.
WILL HEAR TESTIMONY. FROM ALL
OTHERS WHO ARE HERE IN PERSON
THAN VIDEO CONFERENCE THAT ON
THE PHONE IN THAT ORDER AGAIN
IN PERSON FIRST. THEN VIDEO
CONFERENCE THAN FALL. IF YOU'RE
NOT MAIN WITNESSES I WANT TO BE
CLEAR YOU MUST ONLY STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY. AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. IF
YOU SAY MORE THAN THOSE THREE
THINGS I'LL SAY THANK YOU WE
HAVE TO GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS
AT THIS POINT THE MODERATE OR
MEET YOUR COMMENTS AND WE'LL
MOVE. GO TO THE WITNESSES.
THERE WILL BE A BRIEF PAUSE
DURING THE TRANSITION OF
AUTHORS THAT WHEN MISSUS SO I
ASKED THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ON THE PUBLIC BE
PATIENT HOURS WORKED AS JUST.
UNDER UNDER. IF WE HAVE ANY
ISSUES. TECHNOLOGY WHAT TO A
QUICK. TO RESOLVE THEM. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN AUTHORS. WILL PROCEED
THROUGH ARGENTA AND FOLLOW
ORDERS EXCEPT WHERE AN AUTHOR
HAS MULTIPLE BILLS TO PRESENT.
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE HAVE
BILLS. THAT WILL BE HEARD TODAY
WILL GO AFTER ALL NON COMMITTEE
AUTHORS HAVE PRESENTED THEIR
BILLS. SO WITH SO BEFORE FOR
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR
FREEDOM FOR A BRIEF MOMENT. SO
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS THE TIME
ACTIONS ARE HEARING ONLINE IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM OR ON
THE PHONE. SO THAT OUR FIRST
AUTHOR IN THE FALL ORDERS
PRESENT AND THE HEARING ROOM IS
READY TO PRESENT THEIR BILL. SO
WITHOUT MISTER SECRETARY WITH
COLORADO STOP SHOULD FORM. YEAH
HERE CALL YOU COOLEY. WHO WERE
PRESENT ALL IN ALL THE FEAR.
WOULD YOU A QUORUM SO THAT JUAN
WITH THIRD FIRST I'D A TWO TWO
THREE FOUR CHAO. THE. NUMBER.
EIGHTY TWENTY THIRTY FOUR WILL
ALLOW THE PERSONNEL COMMITTEE
AND COOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT WE SEPARATE
INDEPENDENCE LEGAL RIGHT. FROM
THE DISPLAY ATTORNEY YOUR.
COMPROMISED BY A CAR OF
INTEREST. JUDGE NOT OVER YES.
WHAT GOOD MORNING THIS CHAIRMAN
AND AB TWO TWO FOUR WILL ALLOW
THE PERSON COME OF CHANGE AND
COME CALLED. SOMEONE'S MUTED
NEW TO HAVE ME PHONE. PLEASE
YOU. CONTINUE. MR OVER IF I MAY.
AB TWENTY THIRTY WILL ALLOW
PERSON CAN OF AND CALL THIS TWO
SIX UP IN THE LEAGUE
REPRESENTATION FROM THE
DISTRICTS ATTORNEY WHEN A
MAJORITY OF THE CAN BELIEVE THE
ATTORNEY ARE CALM. BY A CAR OF.
PERSONNEL CAN ARE CIVIL SIR
SYSTEM IS THAT IN THIS ARE
THEIR EMPLOYEES FAIRLY. ONE OF
THE MAJOR FUNCTIONS OF A
PERSONNEL COMMISSION TO HEAR
AND THIS. ON THE DISTRICT
DISCIPLINARY ACTION IN OTHER
WORDS THE COMMISSION ACTS IN
EQUITIES ARE JUDICIAL CAPACITY
REGARDING THE DISTRICTS ACTIONS.
GENERALLY THE COMMISSION
RECEIVED THEIR COUNSEL FROM THE
SAME LAWYERS THAT WORK FOR THE
DISTRICT. HOWEVER WHAT IF IT
MISSION WOULD RATHER RECEIVE
LEGAL ADVICE FROM OUTSIDE
COUNSEL ON SEPARATE MATTERS
BECAUSE IT SEES A CONFLICT WITH
THE DISTRICT LAWYER'S ADVICE.
ON THE CURRENT LAW
COMMISSIONERS LACKED THE POWER
TO DECIDE WHAT IT THEY MAY
RECEIVE COUNSEL FROM ANYONE
OTHER THAN THE DISTRICTS
LAWYERS. AS A RESULT THE
PERSONNEL COMMISSION HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO REFUSE COUNSEL
FROM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHEN
HE FINDS APPROPRIATE. AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR WILL PROVIDE
PERSONNEL COMMISSION IS THE
RIGHT TO RETAIN INDEPENDENT
LEGAL COUNSEL WHEN A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST EXIST BETWEEN THE
GOVERNING BOARD AND THE
COMMISSION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR DRIVER. THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT SAID YOU DO HAVE-
TO- FOLKS FOR SUPPORT. DELORES
DERON FLOORS AND GEORGE CALLS
YOUR PHONE. GOOD MORNING MR
SEVEN MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE
LORD AND FOR THE RECORD THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WITH THE- OF AB TWO
KIDS. FOUR WELL ALLOWED FOR
PERSONAL. THEY'RE RIGHT AND THE
CREDIT LEGAL HOW WHEN A BUT OF
IN EXIST BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE
AND THE DEATH. THAT'S RIGHT IS
GIVEN THE PER COMMISSION BY
BLOOD YEARS OF WRECKING THAT
THERE WILL EVIDENCE BECOME OF
INTEREST PERSONAL COMMISSION
AND THE THREE. THE DEFICIENCY
IN LAW IS THAT DISTRICT LAWYERS
ALONE THE SIDE OF THE CAR EVENT
SIX NOT THEIR CLIENTS NOW.
DISCONNECT FINANCING PREVENT
AND CAN SERVER THAT SOME
COMMISSIONS FROM HIGH THERE ARE
LAWYER ONE EXAMPLE THE DISTRICT
SUPPORTED BIELEMA OF MARRIAGE
DISTRICT THERE WAS A DISPUTE
BETWEEN THE DEATH IN THE OF A
THE ELECT PROP. WITH
INDEPENDENTLEGAL ADVICE AND
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF DISTRICTS A
FEW FIFTY A PERSONNEL WHO
WITHIN. AT FIVE EXISTING FOR
COMMISSIONER THAT REQUIRE UNDER
LAW. THE DISTRICT OF WHAT TO
THE COMMISSION WITHIN A THE
COMMISSION WITH AN ELDER BASED
ON IS THE YOU GET BACK CHECKS A
CANDIDATE CONTESTED DELEGATE.
WENT TO COURT IN SECURITY AND
CLEARING NAME THE DISTRICT WITH
YOU HERE. THE BILL THE THIRD IS
NEUTRAL DECISION MAKERS ON
EMPLOYEE IF YOU. WANT
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE HURT
WHEN CONDITIONERS. COMMISSION
DENIED THEIR RIGHT TO
INDEPENDENTLY ACCOUNTABLE OUR
JOB HANG IN ABOUT. THE FAA
BELIEVES IT'S WRONG TO ALLOW
DISTRICT LEGAL COUNSEL TO THE
GATE KEEPER OF WEATHER
CONDITIONS CAN PICTURE THEIR
OWN COUNSEL HERE WHERE OF ANY
OTHER LAW THAT ALLOWS LAWYERS.
TO DETERMINE WHO REPRESENTS THE
HIGHEST AND NOT THE OTHER WAY
AROUND AB TWO TO THREE FOUR
REMEDY THE PROBLEM BY ALLOWING
COMMISSION TO THE SIDE OF A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST THE-
MAJORITY THAT THE COMMISSION.
THIS IS A FAIR AND REASONABLE
APPROACH YES. ASK FOR YOU I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU DOORS THEIR
JOY HOME. YEAH THE CALL GOT
MORE MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOE CALLED AN IRON
WORKER THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
HELP MAKE. SURE EVERYTHING WAS
PRETTY BAD SERVICE SAYS THE
EXACTLY CORRECT YOU'RE A GREAT
JOB WITH VERY DISTRICTS.
DISCHARGED A THE LAST TEN YEARS
BACK TO THE FLOOR. PUBLIC
SCHOOL FIRST FINISH THE DEFENSE.
MEMBERS FALL OUR WORK WITH ALL.
DISTRICT MANAGER. THE PERSONNEL
COMMITTEE TO TALK ON. PROVIDE.
THANK YOU FOR THE BOY.
COMMISSIONER FENCED TO ENSURE
SMOOTH BOX BUT APARTHEID'S.
YOUR READING THE CHIP OF THE
BECAUSE SHOULD THE END. OF THE
HELPED. THANK YOU YOUR CODE
FORTY FIVE TO FIFTY FOUR AND
FORTY FIVE TO FIFTY FOUR WE'RE-
MAKING A COMMISSION OFF JERRY
IN THE- FOR HER SO THAT BOXING
BUT AND ABOUT SUPERVISOR ITS
OWN BACK. AND FINANCIAL IN THE
THAT. FORM BUT YOU. KNOW 5% OF
THE COUNCIL IS WELCOME BOB
COMMISSION. MOST WITH THE-
WHICH DIRECTOR STAFF. COMPLEX
DOUBLE NATURE WITH THE BIG THEY
USE THAT NOT LOCAL. AND
POTENTIAL WORKS FOR THE VICTORY
AND OR- TO SEXUAL THE PH. AND
YEAH THIS CALL MAY COMPLY
COMPLAINTS AGAINST THAT. THE
DOCTORS GOVERNMENT CODE
RESURGENT OKAY ARE NOT POCKETS
FOR. THE LEGAL COUNSEL IN THE
COMMITTEE TO THAT ON THE DAILY
THE COUNCIL. AT 5% WHEN BOXES
CAUGHT BY SERVICE THE BANDIT.
THANK HAVE HAVE DUG INTO
POSITION. BILL TRANSPORT YOUR
PROVIDE YOU TO RELY THAT OF
THAT PERCENT FOR. THE MORE MORE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. I AND
RESENTMENT BECAUSE TO GRAB
FORCE DIALOGUING. YES FULLY
GOAL WHO WITH THOUGHT THAT THIS.
UNDER PRESSURE TO CONTENDER FOR
BOY NOW TO THE COMPU. THE THAT
WE NEED ARE TRYING WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR
COMMISSION THANK YOU FOR HI BUT-
THANK YOU GEORGE AND WE SO
THOSE WITH ONLY TWO MAY
WITNESSES OR HAVE WORK DONE. SO
NOW WE MOVE ON TO THE NON MAY
WITNESS. WANT TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. JUST REMIND THEM OR
MEET THE PHONE IF THEY'RE NOT
SPEAKING AND THEY MUST ONLY
STATE THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION. IF WITHOUT SAID- WILL
GO TO IN PERSON IS THERE ANY
OTHER FOLKS HERE- IN PERSON WHO
WOULD LIKE TO- PROVIDE THE
POSITION. SEEN ON HERE IN
PERSON A LET'S GO OUT ON VIDEO
IS THERE ANYBODY ON VIDEO THEY
WERE LIKE TO PROVIDE- STATEMENT
FOR A POSITION. SEEN ON ON
VIDEO HOW ABOUT OF VIA PHONE
ANYONE ON PHONE WANTED TO
PROVIDE- THERE WERE POSITION ON
THIS BILL. HEARING NONE ALONE
AND BRING IT BACK UP BY. UP TO
THE MEMBER. WAS WAS THERE
SOMEBODY VIA PHONE. GO BACK TO
YOUR PHONE NOT AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU SIR THANK YOUS
WITHOUT BRING BACK UP. TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YEAH BILLS MOVED IN SECOND MODE
BARS COOPER THE SECOND BY
MYSTIC GONZALEZ. OF SOME NUMBER
LIKE TO CLOSE. UP I JUST WANT
US ARMS RACE I'M SORRY STRENGTH.
YOU HAD A QUESTION. THE MASK
THANK YOU HE SAID ASSUME WE'RE
NOT TAKING OPPOSITION THEM SO I
WAS GONNA SAY MY COMMENTS UNTIL
AFTER OPPOSITION BUT I THINK
THIS IS A AS AN ATTORNEY I
CAN'T BELIEVE THIS ISN'T THE
LAW. I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IS ALLOWS.
TO BE DECLARED BY SOMEONE WHO
HAVE THE CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
I THANK YOU- MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD TO
PROTECT OUR EMPLOYEES THANK YOU
FOR. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WITH THAT SAID- SOMETHING LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT- I USED
TO SERVE AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
OUR AND HAD A CHANCE TO WORK
WITH- THE PERSONAL COMMISSION-
AS WELL AND DAHLE ON MANY
OCCASIONS WE WERE REPRESENTED
BY ONE SINGLE ATTORNEY- AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
WE- PAT ISSUE THAT. AT PRESENT
NO CONFLICT OF INTEREST. BUT
THERE WERE OCCASIONS WHERE WE
HAD TO A SEEK INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL FOR THE PERSONNEL
COMMISSION- BECAUSE OF THE DOES
A POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF
INTEREST SO. SO I YELL I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
I- DO YOU SEE ANY FOR THIS BILL
AND JUST WILL RESOLVE A LOT OF
THE ISSUES. ARE AT HAND SO
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THE- FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND I ASKED WE
LIVE BY THE- SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER BREMER CHAU LIKE TO
THANK. THANK YOU FOR THE BILL I
THINK IT'S A GOOD BUILDING YOUR
FLEXIBILITY TO. PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONS REGARDING LEGAL
REPRESENTATION WHICH I
SHOULD'VE AND ON A LONG TIME
AGO. SO THAT I DO HAVE OUR
RECOMMENDATION SO MISTER
SECRETARY LIKE TO FOLLOW. FOR
THE OTHERS MOTION SICK SO. SICK
CALDERON. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND RIVER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ. AYE
VOEPEL. RIGHT COOLEY. COOPER
FONG O'DONNELL RAY AS. SIX BUT
WITHOUT WAS SIX OR KEEP IT ON
CALL. THANK YOU. WITHOUT SET
BEFORE GOING TO THE NEXT BILL
ARE JUST NOW THAT WE DO HAVE
AND A QUORUM STUFF WHICH- I
WANT TO GO AHEAD MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NEW MEMBER
LIKE TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVED BY
O'DONNELL SEKHEMRE MISTER
COOPER- SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MOTION
IS TO PASS AND BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS CONSENT
CALENDAR RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL.
COOLEY COOPER- FONG O'DONNELL
RADIUS. CONSENT COUNTERS THAT
WILL KEEP IT OPEN SO THAT WILL
LAUNCH OUR NEXT BILL WE HAVE.
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTEEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COME FOR. DO YOU MAY
PRESENT READY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THIS IS AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY A
WITH RESPECT TO A LABOR
DISPUTES AND MOVING THAT OF THE
FOCUS ON THAT OF ON THE ENTITY
TO HELP ASSIST- WITH SUCH
DISPUTES AS NOTED IN THE-
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS ON PAGE FOUR
ALSO THIS IS VERY SIMILAR TO
PRIOR. A RELATED LEGISLATION AS
A NUMBER OF OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ALSO A PROVIDED A
WE'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
THAT OF THE BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT AS WELL AS TO CONTINUE
THAT DIALOGUE TO WORK OUT ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES AND- OF
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I VOTE AS IT DAYS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE CURRENTLY.
THE BILL. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SOME REYES SECOND BY
RESTORED LONG IF YOU DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE WE
HAVE- TERRY BRENNAN WHO'S ON
VIA VIDEO. TERRY IS. THEIR
YOUNG CON VIDEO. IN SUPPORT. I
AM CAN YOU HEAR ME OWN YOUR VIA
PHONE OR YOUR NOW YOU. HEY HOW
YOU DOING DEREK COULD FACE FOR
PHONE BUT I AM ON VIDEO. SEIU
CALIFORNIA'S- SPONSORED SPORTS
HIS BILL- STRONGLY- THIS IS NOT
UNLIKE WHAT IS DONE IN TO THE
OTHER LARGEST TRANSIT DISTRICTS
IN CALIFORNIA MT A AND- O. C.
T. A- WE'RE JUST BRINGING PART
INTO THE- SAME. SITUATION THIS
WILL SAVE MONEY- REDUCE LABOR
UNREST AND AS WE WERE COMING
OUT OF THIS CRISIS. OF LABOR
PEACE AND MAKING SURE PEOPLE
CAN GET TO WORK- VIA PUBLIC
TRANSIT IS CRITICAL AND- WE
HOPE YOU- SUPPORT US IN THIS
EFFORT TO- MAKE IT EASIER FOR
MANAGEMENT LABOR TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES BY. AN IMPARTIAL- FAIR
BODY THAT IS PER WITH- DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE IN RESOLVING
THESE ISSUES. WITH I-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU TERRY WITH THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LONELY ONLY HAD
ONE A WITNESS WAS A TERRY. AND
WITHOUT- WILL WANT TO OUR NON
MAIN WITNESSES WHO WANT TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY THOSE COMING
VIA PHONE MAKE SURE YOUR METER
PHONES ONLY STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. AND
WITHOUT WILL GO IN PERSON
ANYONE HERE AND- THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEE
NINE HERE IN PERSON HOW ABOUT
VIA VIDEO ANYBODY VIA VIDEO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE THEIR
POSITION. THANK NONE ABOUT VIA
PHONE ANYBODY VIA PHONE LINE
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE THEIR
POSITION ON THIS BILL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE YOUR
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ON THE GENERAL. WAS THERE
ANYBODY VIA PHONE LIKE TO
PROVIDE PROVIDE THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL. AB TWENTY FOUR
TIMES TO LOW NO. OKAY SEE NONE
ANY COMMENTS ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIKE TO-CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER
LOW THIS MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
TO ME AS WELL I BELIEVE ALL
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
THOSE IN TRANSIT SHOULD BE
UNDER THE PURPOSE JURISDICTION.
AND APPROPRIATE STATE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING LAW THE
PURPOSE THE STATE'S EXPERT IN
DEALING WITH THE PUBLIC CAMPARI
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS I RECOMMEND
AN AYE VOTE MISTER SECRETARY
LIKE COLOR MOTION SECOND YEAH
WE GOT A- O'DONNELL AND COOPER
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TWO
THOUSAND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL NO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER I FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE RADIUS REYES HI.
THANK THE BILLS UP AND GOT FIVE
EYES THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
ONE FILE ITEM IS A. B. THIRTY
SIXTY NINE SO LACKEY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT A. B. THREE ZERO SIX
NINE. ALWAYS ENTERED INTO A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THE SHOULD
NOT TAKE AWAY FROM THE EFFORTS
OF COMBATING HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. AVAIL THANK. THE MOOD
IN SECONDS COOLEY SEKHEMRE
SUPER. WILL BE QUICK. THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS ONLY GET
WORSE WITH THIS- DISCOVERED
NINETEEN CIRCUMSTANCE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL EXPAND PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FORMER FOSTER AND RECENTLY HOME
A FEW. IT PROVIDES AN ALTERNATE
PATHWAY TO CIVIL SERVICE BY
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO
DEMONSTRATE QUALIFICATIONS ON
THE JOB. RATHER THAN COMPLETING
OUR TRADITIONAL CIVIC SUB CIVIC
SERVICE EXAMS I'M SORRY THE
NATIONAL FOSTER YOUTH INSTITUTE
REPORTS OF 50% OF FOSTER YOUTH
AGING OUT OF THE SYSTEM REMAIN
UNEMPLOYED. UNTIL AT LEAST AGE
TWENTY FOUR ADDITIONALLY THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS STATES THAT NEARLY
HALF THE FOSTER YOU POPULATE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AFTER
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF AGING OUT OF
THE SYSTEM. THE YOUTH WHO AGE
OUT OF THE SYSTEM REPORT
FEELING AS THOUGH THEY'VE
EXACERBATED ALL GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES FOR ARGUING THAT IT
WAS A CONDUIT FOR FORMS OF
DEPENDENCY. STORY SHARED WITH
MY OFFICE INCLUDE PROSTITUTION.
DRUG ADDICTIONS AN UNHEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS A CONSTRUCTING
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL IT IS
PRUDENT TO EQUALIZE THE UNIQUE
BARRIERS OF FOSTER YOUTH THE
JUROR FINDING SUITABLE
EMPLOYMENT. THAT IS ESTIMATED
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT'LL BE
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND HOMELESS
FOSTER OR FORMER. FOSTER YOUTH
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM. AND
I DO BELIEVE I HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES. NOT TO ACCESS
REBEKAH GONZALEZ FROM THE
NATIONAL OF SOCIAL. OR IS FROM
CAL WHERE FOR SOCIAL. THANK YOU
SUMMER. WITHOUT WE HAVE REBEKAH
GUNS ALL NARC FLOORS REBECCA IS
VIA. REV OR YOU. ON VIA VIDEO.
ACTUALLY REBEKAH ON THE PHONE
OKAY WITH US JUST AS GET THE GO
AHEAD WHEN THEY'RE READY YEAH
THREE MINUTES. I REBEKAH ABBOTT
AND I REPRESENT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL SOCIAL WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE DEGREES
FROM ACCREDITED SOCIAL WORK
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY
SIXTY NINE AND WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCED NFL
WHICH WILL AFFECT FORMER FOSTER
USE AND HOMELESS YOUTH THAT
PAIN STATE EMPLOYMENT. AT THE
OPERATOR STATED THAT THE
TYPICAL EMPLOYMENT AND THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS YOUTH ARE
DISCOURAGING AND HEARTBREAKING.
DURING A PANDEMIC IT IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT THAT THESE
EITHER A BE EMPLOYED WHICH WILL
HELP FUND TO RETAIN OR OBTAIN
HOUSING. BOB YOU ARE THE-
CHILDREN'S WE ARE HERE TO ONE
THAT EASIEST. MANY WHO HAVE.
ABUSE MOST OF US CAN ABOUT.
BEING ABLE TO GRADUATE FROM THE
SYSTEM AT FULLY FUNCTIONING AND
SUCCESSFUL ABOUT. EMPLOYMENT AS
WE ALLKNOW IT'S NECESSARY TO
SIXTEEN A PROGRAM THAT
FACILITATES EMPLOYMENT OF
BOXING YOU AND HOW MUCH. YOU
WILL HELP THESE GROUPS THE RIDE
TWENTY THREE THAN ANY OF THAT
WITH YOU CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I. BUT-
THANK YOU REBEKAH ODD TO HAVE
ERIC FLOORS ARE YOU ON VIA
PHONE AS WELL. I AM MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR HAVING ME THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION IS THE COORDINATING
AN ADVISORY BODY REPRESENTING
THE FORTY FIVE WORKFORCE BOARDS
IN THE STATE. OF THE NONPROFIT
AND THE DPW A REPRESENT THOSE
LOCAL BOARDS AND THEY SERVE
OVER ONE MILLION CUSTOMERS AND
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES
BUT A HUNDRED NINETY THREE
CLEAR CENTERS. ARE NUMBERS WORK
THE PLATE. JOB SEEKERS INTO
CAREERS WITH UPWARD MOBILITY
THAT WILL HAVE LONG TERM
POSITIVE ECONOMIC EFFECTS FOR
CLIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
LOCAL BOARDS ARE ALSO USED TO
PROVIDING PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES UNDER
THE FEDERAL COMPREHENSIVE
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING ACT OUR
MEMBERS PROVIDED A VARIETY OF
SERVICES TO ELIMINATE BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES PARTICIPANTS WERE
PROVIDED TRAINING INCLUDING
CLASSROOM TRAINING ON THE JOB
TRAINING AS WELL AS ENGLISH AS
A SECOND LANGUAGE AND GT
SERVICES FOR THOSE. WHO ARE
LIMITED IN. THANK BASIC SKILL
DEFICIENT WORKS LIKE TO
PROVIDER BECAME THE MENTORS AND
FACILITATED TRANSITION TO
PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT. NUMEROUS
PUBLIC SECTOR AND PARTICIPANTS
WERE TRAINED ON THE JOB TO FILL
VACANCIES AND APPLIED FOR THE
SAME POSITION. AND MANY OF
THOSE WERE IN THE CIVIL
SERVICE. MANY OF OUR DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANTS STARTED WORK
WITH. A PUBLIC SERVICE
EMPLOYMENT AND THE WEEK PROGRAM
WOULD PROVIDE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP TRANSITION
AS VULNERABLE YOUTH IN TWO
PROMINENT ON SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT. LOCAL BOYS OFTEN
ARE EITHER HOUSE IN OR PARTNER
WITH CITY AND COUNTY AGENCIES
THAT WORK WITH THIS POPULATION.
THANK TO PROVIDE RESOURCES AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM A. B. THREE ZERO SIX NINE
TARGETED PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR
CAN PROVIDE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AS WELL WITHOUT THOSE ARE
THE ONLY TWO THAT WE HAVE
LISTED NOW WE'LL GO TO THE NON
MAIN WITNESSES WHO WANT TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY THEIR
POSITION. IF YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING REMEMBER TO ONLY TO
MEET YOUR PHONE AND ONLY STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IMPOSITION. WITHOUT WILL GO TO
IN PERSON ANYBODY HERE IN THE
ROOM. WISH TO PROVIDE FOR THE
POSITION FOR OR AGAINST. SEEN
NONE IN PERSON. ABOUT VIA VIDEO
ANYBODY VIA VIDEO WHO LIKE TO
STATE THEIR POSITION. SEEING
NONE BE A VIDEO ABOUT VIA PHONE
ANYBODY VIA PHONE OR LIKE TO
STATE THEIR POSITION ON.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY NINE.
ID LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PRIEST. PRESS ONE
BUTTON THERE AT THIS TIME.
LOOKS LIKE NOBODY ON IF YOU
HAVE A FEW. WE ACTUALLY HAVE
SEVERAL JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
OKAY.
ONCE AGAIN ANYBODY VIA
PHONE GOING SPEAK- GIVE THEIR
POSITION. THANK YOU CALL YET
CALLER GO AHEAD YES HE WE MAKE
IT PRETTY GOOD. THANK YOU SORRY
ABOUT THAT GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS TIFFANY
JONES I SERVE AT THE SOUTHERN
VICE CHAIR WITH THE- FOR. MR ON
THE FOR THE PURPOSE-
INTERRUPTED HERE WHAT WE'LL GET
HER BACK IN JUST A MOMENT MY
APOLOGIES
.
THANK YOU SORRY ABOUT THAT
AGAIN- MY NAME IS TIFFANY JONES
I IN THE SOUTHERN VICE CHAIR
FOR THE SOLANO COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND I AM IN SUPPORT AT A. B.
THREE ZERO SIX NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE VIA
PHONE LIKE TO STATE THE
POSITION. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
ONE MOMENT PLEASE OKAY. FRANK
WOULD YOU LIKE TO STATE YOUR
POSITION. SURE BOB THIS IS
FRANK FRANK THANK YOU I'M
OPPOSING ARE NOT PUTTING. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE LIKE STATE THE
POSITION VIA PHONE. NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU AND WITH THAT SAID OR BRING
IT BACK UP TO THE COMMITTEE ANY.
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU'D LIKE
TO. HAVE A COMMENT THANK YOU
MISTER OF MYST LACKEY I REALLY
LIKE YOUR BILL I LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE EXTEND THIS I KNOW
THAT THEIR SOMETHING SIMILAR
FOR THOSE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THERE WAS A QUESTION ABOUT TO
THE ACRONYM BEING USED ARE YOU
CONSIDERING A CHANGE IN THE
AKRON THEM OR HOW IS IT GOING
TO BE DISTINGUISHED. I HAVE NOT
HEARD OF THE SACRAMENT CONFLICT
BUT I PROMISE THAT THAT WILL BE
RESOLVED. AB MY NEXT. COMMENT
ACTUALLY QUESTION IS YOU ARE
YOU ACCEPTING CO AUTHORS I
WOULD LOVE TO JOIN YOU IN THIS
BILL. OF COURSE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
A COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITHOUT
SOME REMEMBERED LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS BILL AND- BECAUSE
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION SURE THAT ONE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE PARTS OF
OUR POPULATION. WILL HAVE AN
EQUITABLE PATH TO A CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYMENT WHICH I
BELIEVE THEY DESERVE. THANK YOU
WITH THAT SAID I REALLY LIKE
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE AS
WELL. I KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROOMS JUST MAY COME INTO THE
ACRONYM I THINK- THERE WERE
SOME DISCUSSION AND ANALYSIS
REGARDING THAT MAYBE THE NAME
TO THE TITLE. BUT OTHER THAN
THAT IT'S A GREAT BILL LOOK FOR
THE MOVEMENT THIS BILL FORT
WORTH WITH THAT I RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE. SO MISTER SECRETARY LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL. AND I BELIEVE
WE DO ALREADY. HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND. OKAY THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ. HI RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL. AYE VOEPEL AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. WHO COOPER
AYE FONG FONG AYE O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE RADIUS. RAY IS.
THE BILL'S UP THINGS WERE MUCH
THANK YOU FOR. NEXT IN FILE
ITEM WE HAVE AB. THIRTY NINETY
SIX. SUMMER CHAU URINE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD. THIS IS A COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD AGREE HOW
UNACCEPTABLE IT IS TO DENY A
WORKER THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE
UNFORTUNATELY DURING THE PAST
FEW YEARS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS REPEATEDLY SENT
OUT ANTI UNION COMMUNICATIONS.
TO EXISTING BARGAINING UNITS
AND WORKERS ATTEMPTING TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN AT
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE.
WARNING EMPLOYEES OF SALARY
FREEZES AND A LOSS OF THE
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE
PROFESSIONAL MANAGEMENT WORKING
HOURS. THESE ARE FLAGRANT
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW.
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN IF THE UNION
IS SUCCESSFUL IN PETITIONING
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD TO GRANT AN UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN
DONE. AND THERE WERE NO
MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCES TO THE
UC. ARBIL WILL IMPOSE A
THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY FOR
VIOLATION PER EMPLOYEE. BY
CREATING A FINANCIAL PENALTY
FOR THE DISSEMINATION OF ANTI
UNION COMMUNICATIONS YOU SEE
WOULD CONSIDER CAREFULLY BEFORE
INTENTIONALLY DISCOURAGING
UNION ACTIVITY IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. WE ALL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
SPECIALLY HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROTECT THEM AS THE EXERCISE
ESSENTIAL CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
SUCH AS DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT
TO BE CALM OR REMAIN A MEMBER
OF A UNION. THESE ARE CHOICES
THAT SHOULD BE PRETTY AID.
WITHOUT COERCION OR ON WHAT
SHOULD BE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES. WHAT'S THAT LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT YOU DO
HAVE- THREE- WITNESSES- MATT
BROUGHT FROM TEAMSTERS. AND
SUPPORT LAINEY RICHEST A TEAM
FOR SUPPORT. AND MARK WEBBER
BUT ART FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA POSITION SO MATT
SELECT YOUR FIRST VIA PHONE.
SHARE YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS MAP
RIGHT HERE ON THE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS- WHO ARE
THE PROUD SPONSORS THAT EIGHTY
THIRTY SIXTY NINE. I MAKE BY
COM AT THE SHORTEST POSSIBLE I
JUST WANT TO HAMMER HOME TWO
QUICK POINTS I'M FOR TURNING
OVER MY TIMES ARE SECOND WAY.
THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T SECTION
THIRTY FIVE IF YOU WOULD BE
ACTED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN
LIGHT OF THE JANET DECISION.
COULD NOT THAT PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
DETERRING FOR DISCOURAGING
UNION ORGANIZING ACTIVITIES FOR
THIRTY FIVE FIFTY PER IT IS
THIS CONTACT IT DID NOT CREATE
ANYTHING IN THE WAY OF
PENALTIES. SO IT'S BECOME SORT
OF A TWO THIRDS REMEDY. ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS WITH FEDERAL
ACTION PENDING OCCURRED THE
TEACHERS TO SPEND A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME AND EFFORT WE TO
GETTING THESE CHARGES THE
DETERMINATION WITH NO
CONSEQUENCE THE UC. THAT YOU
SEE VIOLATED SECTION THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY FIFTY YOU SEE ACT
ISSUE A PUBLIC STATEMENT IF
GETTING THAT THE COMMUNICATION
WITH THE VIOLATION OF THE LOCK
I THEN THE ORGANIZING CAMPAIGN
AS LONG AS THERE HAVE BEEN
DEFEATED OR BADLY DAMAGED. AND
LIKE OR KEEP IT OUT COST
BENEFIT NOW. DOWN THE FOR MY
THIRTY FIVE. WELL BUT- IF YOU
CAN. DAY DEFEATING OUR
ORGANIZED. MY TICKET AND FINAL
POINT IS THAT I WAITING SECTION
FIVE IS NOT SOMETHING YOU JUST
WHY INTO. EXTENT IN THE AFTER I
HAD TO PUT THE- YOU CAN
COMPLIES WITH EXISTING LAW THEY
HAVE TO PAY DOLLAR HELP YOU.
ARE IF YOU CAN GET THAT HERE
TODAY SAID THAT WILL COST TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IN ITSELF
IS THE TRADITION THE BIG PLAN
TO CONTINUE ROUTINELY VIOLATING
LAW. WITH ME TODAY FOR YOU
RICHARD PAN WHO WORKED AT THE
DEFEATING AFFAIRS COORDINATOR
YOU DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO FOR THIRTY TWO
YEARS SHE IS NOW AN ORGANIZER
WITH THE TEAM. I'M THAT
MINISTRY TO PROFESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN AT THE HE WILL SPEAK
ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE REGARDING
THESE COMMUNICATION THERE
CHILLING EFFECT. ON ORGANIZING
EFFORTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITHOUT HOW ABOUT. HI GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I BY
IN STRONG SUPPORT AS AB THIRTY
NINETY SIX MY NAME IS BONNIE
RECORD PLAN AND I AM A RETIREE
OF THE UC DAVIS HEALTH SYSTEM
IN SACRAMENTO DURING MY THIRTY
TWO YEARS THIRTY CANYOUR
CAREER AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA I PERSONALLY OBSERVE
YOU SEE. ANTI UNION MESSAGING
AND ITS IMPACT ON MY CO WORKERS.
WHILE WORKING AT UC DAVIS
WORKERS OCCASIONALLY RECEIVED
LETTERS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
WHICH DISCOURAGE STARTING
WAGNER WITH THE UNIONS HAS
OFTEN DISCREDITED THE AND AS A
RESULT IN THE FIGHT EVEN
KNOWING THAT WHAT MANAGEMENT
SAID MIGHT NOT BE TRUE NONE OF
US WOULD ATTEND THE UNION
MEETINGS ARE MEET WITH THE
UNION REPRESENTATIVE.
EVENTUALLY HOWEVER I WAS
CURIOUS ABOUT HOW MY UNION DUES
WERE BEING SPENT SO I ATTENDED
MY FIRST UNION MEETING IN
OAKLAND I FELT THE TAPER OPTION
TO ATTEND IN THE BAY AREA
RATHER THAN TAKE TEN ON MY ON
CAMPUS IN SACRAMENTO. PLEASE
NOTE THAT I HAD THIS MUCH FEAR
EVEN THOUGH MY EVALUATION FOR
CONSISTENTLY EXCEEDS
EXPECTATIONS I AM NOW AN
ORGANIZER FOR THE NATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF TEAMSTERS I WAS
WORKING ON THE UC
ADMINISTRATIVE PROFESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN IN AN EFFORT TO HELP
AND REPRESENTED YOU KEY STAFF
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE UNION.
WHEN DO YOU THINK PLAY HR
DEPARTMENT SENT OUT AN ANTI
UNION LETTER TO STAFF IT BETTER
DISCREDITED TEAM MADE ABOUT PAY
RAISES HER BUT LATER FOUND THE
LETTER TO BE AN ACCURATE AS A
RESULT OF THE LETTER I WAS
IMMEDIATELY CONTACTED BY
SEVERAL WORKERS AT. A. PAUL AND
CONFUSED IT. IT INSTANTLY
BROUGHT FLASHBACKS CONGRESS. I
HAD MICHAEL. AB A WORK HAVE
THAT CONCERNS THAT CAN. AS WE
OUR THEY WERE IT. AND DESCRIBE
A BC I. GLASS. SHORTLY AFTER I.
SEVERAL LET YOU LEARN MEETINGS
VARY FROM CASE AT THE FEEL LIKE
THAT. THE UCLA. UNION LETTER AT
THE BECAME KNOWN AS ALWAYS BUT
AT BY YOU CAN BEAT. I WAS TOLD
MULTIPLE TIMES BY MANY THAT
THEIR CO WORKERS HAD PLANNED ON
ATTENDING THAT WERE TOO AFRAID
AFTER RECEIVING THE LATTER.
OFTENTIMES A REPRESENTATIVE
WITH THAT HAD THE MEETING WITH
THE LIST OF QUESTIONS. WHEN I
ASKED IF I COULD CONTACT YOU CO
WORKERS DURING THEIR FAKE OR
NON WORK TIME TO PERSONALLY
AFFECT THE CONCERNED. SELECT
RESENTED IT WITH A- FOOT
USUALLY STAY THERE REALLY
AFRAID. BUT I LET THEM. CLASS
MATTER OCCASION TO TINKER QUIRK
FOR PER YEAH AT AND KICKED THE
OF AN ALL THAT YOU SEE AT THE
BY AND REPRESENTATIVE AT THE UC
ACT FOR CAN'T BUT WHEN INFORMED
OF THE A LEAK OUT OF THE MAN
REPRESENTATIVE YELLED WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO THINK JIMMY HOP
ON ME AND THEN CALL THE CAMPUS
FROM THE ORGANIZERS MANY
EMPLOYEE OR EMPLOYEES AFTER
DEFENDER ACTION AND NEWS ABOUT
IT STEP THROUGH THE BUILDING
CAUSING REAL FEAR AMONG STAFF
KILLING THE ABILITY OF THE YOU.
CAN GAUGE WITH WORKERS FIFTEEN
WHICH CAN SOMETIMES BUT NINE
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT ON UNION
ORGANIZING BOTH INCIDENTS LIKE
WERE LATER FOUND. BY PER TO
VIOLATE. THE YEAR. DOES NOT
SEEM TO IT NEXT. AKON NOR IT'S-
IT ONLY BE USED. FOR A
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS CAL LABOR
LAW THAT RATHER THAT HAVE BEEN
IN COMMITTEE BILLY WHO DID NOT
MEMBERS OF THE OWN COMMUNITY.
RIGHT UNDER HERE A TO LEARN
ABOUT AND WHETHER THEY WILL A
UNION AND HOW COLLECTED.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN ONCE SAID THERE
IS NO ONE THERE WITHOUT LABOR
AND LEAST THE ONE THAT ROB
OTHER. RECEIVE CAL NEEDS TO BE
HOW ACCOUNT FOR THEIR ACTIONS
FOR THE ABOVE REASONS I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B. THIRTY
NINETY. THANK YOU WITHOUT WE
HAVE A MICHAEL NEXT FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ARE
YOU ON VIA PHONE. I AM ON THE
PHONE THANK YOU ALL. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS MY
NAME IS MICHAEL THE DARK FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OFF FOR THE PRESIDENT.
UNIVERSITY WITH THE PROP
UNIONIZED EMPLOYER WITH OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES AND PROVIDES GENEROUS
BENEFITS AND HEALTH AND
RETIREMENT AND WAGES. TO THOSE
EMPLOYEES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE AB THREE ZERO NINE SIX.
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THREE
FIVE FIVE ZERO- WHICH SIR BROAD
MENTIONED EARLIER PROHIBITS ALL
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FROM
DISCOURAGING UNION MEMBERSHIP.
THE MEASURE THINK ABOUT THE
UNIVERSITY FOR VIOLATIONS UNDER
THAT SECTION. AND THAT CREATES
ON EVEN PLAYING FIELD WITH
RESPECT TO OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE. IT
ALSO- GENERALLY SPEAKING
CHANGES. I IT CREATED MAJOR
DEPARTURE FROM THE CURRENT
PRACTICE A PER. GENERALLY
SPEAKING THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RELATIONS FOR ISSUES THE FIRST
ORDERS IN MAKING. AND IN MAKING
CERTAIN CASES- THEY CAN AWARD
MAKE WHOLE REMEDY THEY DO NOT
THE FINES AND PENALTIES AND
THIS MAJOR DEPARTURE FROM
CURRENT PRACTICE IS
PROBLEMATIC. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTY NINETY SIX AND A HALF
BILLION OF UP. THANK YOU
WITHOUT SAID THOSE ARE THE
THREE LISTED THERE ARE DONE
FIGHT BY THE MEMBER NOW WE WILL
GO ON TO THE NON ME WITNESSES
WHO WANT TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
ALSO JUST REMIND FOLKS METER
PHONE IF YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING IN
ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. AND
WHAT THAT WILL GO TO IN PERSON.
ANYONE HERE AND NOT. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THIRTY
NINETY SIX. SEE NONE IN PERSON
ABOUT VIA VIDEO ANYBODY VIA
VIDEO HERE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON A. B. THIRTY
NINETY SIX. SEE NONE VIA VIDEO
HOW ABOUT VIA PHONE ANYBODY VIA
PHONE WOULD LIKE TO ADD THEIR
NAMES SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO.
A. B. THIRTY NINETY SIX OF YOUR
PHONE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
FEW IN Q. IN OUR MIND OR TO
OTHERS TO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
DO. WISH TO SHARE LINE EIGHTY
SIX IN LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
TRANSPORT. THANK YOU AND ONE
ACTIVE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING EXCEPT BRAMBLE HERE ON
BEHALF OF MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
SUBJECT YUP THE EXPAND TO OTHER
EMPLOYERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE THEM VIA PHONE. ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MICHELLE
CASTRO SERVICE PLAYS
INTERNATIONAL UNION OFTEN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE NEXT. WE HAVE TWO MORE
NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE SEVENTEEN.
HI THIS IS THE ONLY ADDRESSING
THAT THE AMERICAN THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MEDICAL WAIT AND TALK ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANYONE NEXT. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE ONE MOMENT LINE
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS IT NOT JUST
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
WAS THERE ANYONE ELSE VIA PHONE.
ONE OF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITHOUT OR BRING HERE TO
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AS HAVE ACCOUNT
FOR REALLY ENTERED THIS
COMMITTEE NOT YOU SO MUCH
MISTER THROUGH FOR THIS THIS
BILL I THINK THAT WHEN WE HAVE
LAWS THAT PROTECT OUR WORKERS
IF THE LAWS HAVE NO TEETH TO
THEM IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
ARE. MAKING SURE THAT IT ISN'T
JUST SAYING YOU CAN'T DO IT
SAYING IF YOU DO IT THERE WILL
BE CONSEQUENCES. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK MOST
PEOPLE WOULD AGREE THAT A JOB
AT THE UC IT'S A GREAT JOB. AND
OF MOST EVERYONE WHO IS IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT. BUT I THINK THAT
THERE HAVE TO BE PROTECTIONS
FOR THE EMPLOYEES. AND THEY
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO. TO SHARE
THEIR GRIEVANCES WITHOUT.
REPERCUSSIONS AND I THINK THE
UNIVERSITY NEEDS TO BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE ONE THEY DO- WHEN
THEY DO NOT ABIDE BY THAT SO
THANK YOU. FOR THIS. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD- THE COMMOTION OF
THE BILL. SECOND OF A MOTION
SECOND MOTION BY SOME MEMBER AS
SECOND BY. WHICH COOLEY AT ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMENTS. SAYING ON SOME
REMEMBERED LIKE CLOSE. A
PERFECT EUROPE CONSIDERATION
THIS BILL LET ME JUST RESPOND A
FEW THINGS THAT ARE FOR FROM
THE UC- FIRST OF ALL THEY
WONDER WHY IT APPLIES TO THEM
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW
IF THERE'S A FUTURE BILL THAT
WOULD APPLY TO MORE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS OR OTHER PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS THAT SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT BUT THE REALITY IS IN
RECENT YEARS THE UC HAS BEEN
THE MOST EGREGIOUS VIOLATOR. OF
IN THIS AREA AND DESPITE
WARNINGS AND PROMISES TO DO
BETTER THEY'VE CONTINUED TO
FLAUNT THE LAW AND AS- ARE
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE- DOLLARS
COMES REYES JUST MENTION- AT
THIS MOMENT THERE'S REALLY NO
TEETH- EVEN IF THE EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND PETITION PER TO
GRANT AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CHARGE PER CAN ONLY ISSUE A
CEASE AND DESIST ORDER. BY THE
TIME THAT NOTICE THE DAMAGE HAS
BEEN DONE AND SO WE THINK THAT
THERE MAY BE JUST A LITTLE BIT
AS PARTY FROM I ALSO WANT TO
JUST REITERATE THE FACT THAT
IT'S NOT EASY TO VIOLATE THE
LAW ON THE SITUATIONS YOU SEE
HAS TO TAKE CONCERTED STEPS TO
STAND UP ANTI UNION MEDICATIONS
AND- AND THAT'S NOT A TRIVIAL
MATTER STAND BLESSING I WANT TO
SAY. YOU KNOW AT THIS TIME
PERIOD NOW THAN. WORKERS NEED
TO SPEAK UP TO VOICE CONCERNS
PARTICULARLY AROUND WORKPLACE
SAFETY. AND A PUBLIC EMPLOYER
SHOULD NOT BE DISCOURAGING
CHILLING OR OTHERWISE SPORTING.
UNION ORGANIZING. A SPECIALLY
IN VIOLATION OF LAW SO WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SUMMER SEEMS
TO ME IS WHAT THIS THAT WE KEEP
HEARING MORE MORE ABOUT ABUSES
REGARDING. EMPLOYEE RIGHTS AND
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE UC. SEEMS TO ME
THIS BILL IS A GOOD FIT TO HELP
REDUCE ELIMINATE SOME OF THESE
PROBLEMS SO THAT EMPLOYEES
RIGHTS ARE NOT ABUSE. I ALSO
RECOMMEND AYE VOTE AND WITH
THAT SET MISTER SECRETARY LIKE
CALDERON. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
OH NINE SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHIU. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ HI.
RODRIGUEZ I'D VOEPEL. VOEPEL NO
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER HI FONG. FONG NOTE
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE AREAS.
RAY AS HI. THE MOTION IS FAST
FIVE TAPES THANK YOU. FOR NECRO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B.
THIRTY THREE ZERO TWO MR SALAS.
GOOD MORNING. WHEN YOU READY
SERVE SIGNATURE MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
THREE OH TWO WHICH WOULD RATIFY
THE AMMO YOU THAT IS CURRENTLY
BEING NEGOTIATED BETWEEN
BARGAINING UNIT SIX IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
WITH THAT I'LL JUST SAY THAT-
DEMO YOU IS SET TO EXPIRE ON
JULY SECOND AND THAT'S WHY THE
ARE JUST. BUT THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE WITH THE MOTION AND
SECOND. PART WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE A MATT EASILY. FROM C. C.
P. AWAY- AND SUPPORT VIA PHONE.
MATT ARE YOUR BILL WILL BE A
PHONE. I AM THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MATT USUALLY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WHERE THE SPONSORS
OF AB THIRTY THREE OH TWO WHICH
WOULD RATIFY THE EVENTUAL
AGREEMENT BETWEEN OUR THIRTY
EIGHT AND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO THINK
IT'S ONLY A RESULT FOR OFFERING
THE BILL. AWAY REPRESENT NEARLY
THIRTY THOUSAND CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS AND PROBABLY CAN
THAT PROVIDE IN FEDERAL SERVICE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND EVERY DAY OUR MEMBERS PLATE
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO
ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY. IN THE
DISTRICT NOW MORE THAN EVER
WITH THE CONSTANT LOOMING
THREAT. OF IN NINETEEN IN OUR
STATE. AWAY CRIED TO CREATE THE
MOST EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
CORRECTIONAL SETTING POSSIBLE
AND WE'RE MORE THAN WILLING TO
DO OUR PART TO ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND A CRITICAL
COMPONEN THAT IS INSURING THAT
THE STATE WORKFORCE FEEL VALUED
APPRECIATED AND THEY POINT
PERFORMING A VERY DANGEROUS
INVOLVED JOB. OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT PROVIDE
THE FOUNDATION FOR THE ON GOING
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE STATE AND GETTING PEOPLE A
MEMBERSHIP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESS OUR SUPPORT BRADY THIRTY
THREE OH TWO. I REQUEST YOUR I.
BUT- THANK YOU MATT AND WHAT
THAT. SUMMER SALAS AT THE GMAT
WAS ONLY WHEN THEY HAVE LISTED
AS A- MAIN WITNESS. SO THAT
WILL WANT TO THE NON MAIN
WITNESSES- AND WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE US. ALSO IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SPEAKING REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE HAVE YOUR PHONE
MUTED. ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION OPPOSITION AND
WITH THAT WE'LL GO TO IN
PERSON. ANYONE A IN THE ROOM
LIKE TO PRESENT. THERE ARE
OPPOSITION FOR OR AGAINST. SAY
NONE VIA VIDEO ANYBODY VIA
VIDEO WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
TO THEIR POSITION ON A. B.
THIRTY THREE OH TWO. VIA VIDEO.
OUGHT TO HAVE SOMEBODY IN.
DONNA WHAT WITHOUT HOW ABOUT
VIA PHONE ANYBODY VIA PHONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO STATE A POSITION
ON ONCE AGAIN A. B. THIRTY
THREE ZERO TWO. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO STATE YOUR POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON THERE
OUT THIS TIME. NO ONE ON THE
PHONE THAT THE TIME. NO ONE ON
THE PHONE CAN WITHOUT WILL
BRING A BACK UP TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANYBODY LIKE TO HAVE
COMMENT. SEEING NONE THEY WE DO
HAVE A MOTION IN THE SECOND. I
DO I LIKE THIS BILL GOOD BUILT
MOVE FORWARD AND WITH THAT I
RECOMMEND AYE VOTE AND MISTER
SECRETARY OR JACK TO CLOSE I'M
SORRY. JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE LET'S- RESPECT
OUR CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY LIKE CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THREE ZERO
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS THE
RECOMMENDATION THE ACTION THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ. HI
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPELNO VOEPEL
NO COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER HI FONG. FONG I
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I RAY AS
RAY IS. OKAY THE BILL IS UP
THANK YOU. I WOULD LIKE WE CAN
GET A HOLD OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER SHE'S THE NEXT ONE UP. TO
DO THAT. WHICH DOES NOT AT
SCHOOL. THERE'S CONSENT. HI
EVERYONE OUT OF THE STRICKEN.
THE MOTION AND SECOND. SO WITH
THAT MEMBERS I WANT TO GO BACK
ON THE FIRST BILL ON A BEACH.
WAS TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR.
CORRECT CHAO WANT TO LIFT THE
CALL ANNOUNCED THE VOTE WITH
THAT LIKE TO INFORM THE
COMMITTEE THAT THE REGIONAL
MOTION WAS WRONG THE BILL IS
NOT FISCAL. WHEN ASKED IF
THERE'S UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
STRIKE THE PREVIOUS VOTE. AS
UNANIMOUS CONSENT DISTRICT OR
CALL IT'S CALL REFERS. FOR THE
ON CALL ON AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR CHAO THAT WE HAVE A
MISSION MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO.
GIVE YOUR VOTE ALL INCLUDING A
SIMILAR BILL TWO TO THREE FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO. THE
PRIOR MOTION WAS DO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOLEY. COOLEY I.
LARGE ONE MAKE SURE THERE'S
THEIR UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
STRIKE THE PREVIOUS VOTE THAT
WAS- NOT FISCAL YEAH YEAH FOR
YOU IN YOUR IS UNANIMOUS FOR
THE PRIOR VOTE STRICKEN FROM
THE RECORD. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND ASECOND SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TO
THREE FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD THE MOTION IS TO PASS
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ I
VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE COOLEY
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER HI
FONG FONG O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE RADIUS. REYES HI.
THAT WASHES OUT SEVEN ZERO WITH
THAT WE HAVE OUR NEXT BILL. HOW
FAR NUMBER SEVEN A SAY FIVES
WEBER. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING. I WONDER PH<c.cyan>IRST</c>
OF ALL THANK THE STAFF IT'S
WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS BILL
AND- I KNOW IT'S BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES TRYING
TO WORK REMOTELY BUT APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK YOU'VE DONE WITH
THE ANALYSIS I MEAN FOR THE ACA
FIVE THE CALIFORNIA ACT
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THIS
MEASURE WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIANS
OF RECOVERY EFFORTS THAT WE
PLAN TO TAKE- THIS YEAR TO BE
MORE MEANINGFUL IS STEPPED AS
STEPS TO MINIMIZE INEQUALITY
AND PROMOTE ECONOMIC FAIRNSS
FALL. IT'S A FIVE SIX TO
PREVENT CONTINUED
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN.
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR BY ALLOWING
GENDER RACE AND ETHNIC
DIVERSITY TO BE CONSIDERED. AS
ONE OF THE MANY FACTORS IN
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. A PUBLIC
CONTRACTING IN PUBLIC EDUCATION.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX VOTERS
PASSED PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE
WHICH IN THAT THE USE OF RACE
AND GENDER COMES CONSCIOUS
DECISION MAKING IN CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SECTOR. THIS CHANGE BUT
CALIFORNIA OUT OF STEP WITH THE
NATION BEING ONE OF ONLY EIGHT
STATES THAT HAVE HAD THIS BAN
ON EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. AND
SERVES AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO SOLD
LOCAL AND STATE POLICIES TO
ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY FIFTEEN
STUDY WOMEN OWNED AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES LOSE MORE THAN
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. DUE TO THE PASSAGE OF
PROP TWO OH NINE. CAL WITH
CALIFORNIA WENT FROM BEING ONE
OF THE TOP PERFORMING STATES IN
THE COUNTRY. IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES A WITH OUR
CALTRANS THIS- DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE CONTRACTING
AND ESSENCE FALLING TO ONE OF
THE TWO WORST PERFORMING STATE
RELATIVE TO ITS DIVERSITY.
PUTTING IT IN THE COMPANY OF
STATE AS WELL WITH MUCH LESS
DIVERSITY SUCH AS NEBRASKA IN
VERMONT. EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION FOR REMAINS FOR
SYSTEM ACCORDING TO RECENT
RESEARCH 27% OF ASIANS 31% OF
NATIVE AMERICANS 33% OF LATINOS
AND 56% OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
DISCRIMINATION WHEN APPLYING
FOR JOBS. WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR
ALSO A WITNESS HIGH LEVELS OF
DISCRIMINATION WHEN SEEKING
PROMOTIONS ARE EQUAL PAY.
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
DATA REVEALS OF WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO BE UNDER
REPRESENTED AN UNDERVALUED.
ESPECIALLY IN HIGH LEVEL
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS THAT COME
WITH INCREASED RESPONSIBILITY
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION
CONTROLLED IN COMPENSATION. AND
YET RESEARCH DEMONSTRATED THAT
THE MORE REPRESENTATIVE AND
REFLECTIVE OUR CIVIL SERVICE
AND PUBLIC AGENCY ARE THE MORE
RESPONSIVE GOVERNMENT ATTENDS
TO BE. RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES
THAT MINORITY POLICE OFFICER
WITH A LESS LIKELY THAN WHITE
OFFICERS TO CHARACTERIZE
MINORITY CITIZENS AS HOSTILE
ARE IN DIFFERENT TO LAW IT FOR
WATER. BLACK SOCIAL WORKERS
WERE MORE LIKELY TO WITHIN
THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS ARE
PERCEIVED LACK CLIENTS
FAVORABLY. IS WIDELY RECOGNIZED
THE TEACHER DIVERSITY CAN CAN
HAVE A PROFOUND EFFECT ON
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN
STUDENTS. SUCCESSFUL STUDENTS
BUT ONLY THERE 5% OF. T. ARE
TEACHERS OF COLOR. AND WE ARE
BARRED FROM RECOUP THEM BECAUSE
OF PROP TWO OH NINE. EVEN
THOUGH STUDENTS OF COLOR MAKE
UP MRE THAN THREE FOURTHS OF
OUR STUDENT BODY. THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL IS WHEN THE WHEN
THE THOUGHT IS TO BASE MAKE
SURE THAT THE PRODUCT OF AN
ADEQUATE AND INADEQUACIES THAT
WE EXPERIENCE IN THE SOCIETY
ARE DRESSED. EVER OVER TWO
DECADES ACA WOULD PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVISIT AND
EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS ABOUT
REMEDIES FOR GENDER BIAS AND
THE SEVERITY AND TO REMOVE THE
BAN ON EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
EQUIPPING CALIFORNIA WITH THE
TOOLS AGAIN OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION FOR THE HEART OF
CALIFORNIANS. ACA'S ACA HAS
MORE THAN OVER ONE HUNDRED
CIVIL RIGHTS AND LABOR
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING IT
TODAY THE INCLUDING EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY THE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST THE CHINESE AMERICAN
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION ASK ME
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF A
BUSINESS OWNERS THE IN DOUBLE
ACP AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES.
HERE TO TESTIFIED FOR THIS BILL
IS IRWIN COMISKEY WHO IS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR AND DEAN
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW AND
LINDA SCOTT UP A EMPLOYEE FOR
UCSD AND A MEMBER OF ASKED ME.
THANK YOU WITH THAT SAID WE
HAVE LINDA FROM ASKED ME AND OR
ONE FROM THE UC BERKELEY- LINDA
AND- INNER VIA PHONE SO LINDA
WHICH LIKE YOUR FIRST. HELLO
LINDA WITH YES OKAY READY YES
YOU'RE READY OF THREE MINUTES
THANK YOU. ASKING GOOD MORNING-
MY NAME IS WHEN THE GUARD I AM
ONE OF THE TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND PATIENT CARE
WORK IS REPRESENTED BY CAPS MAY
THIRTY TO NINETY NINE I HAVE
WORKED AT UC SAN DIEGO BUT
TWENTY YEARS TWENTY SIX BEER AT
THE PATIENT ACCOUNT.
REPRESENTATIVE I HAVE BEEN
PRETTY MUCH BEEN FILLED WITH
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION YEAH MY
LIGHT. I KNOW ALL I NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT HOW MANY WAYS PEOPLE
WHO HIRE PEOPLE WHAT FINANCING
HIGHER OPTIMAL PEOPLE LIKE ME.
ALRIGHT IN FACT THERE ARE SO
MANY SOMETHING THAT IT TAKES
SEVEN YEAR ONE AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN'S HEART IF THE UC SERVICE
WORKER EARNING A BLACK AT THE
WHITE NAY AND HIGHER GET BANG
DATE AT THE- WORK. EVERYTHING
OUT THERE BARELY OUT. IT ONLY
TAKES SIX YEARS THAT WEEK THEY
WANT. WAIT MAIL SERVICE WORKER.
AND THERE MIGHT AFTER MEREKA CO
WORKERS RETIRED THEY ARE NOT
YEAH WE PLAYED BY AFRICAN
AMERICAN. AND THE LAST TWO
DECADES THE NUMBER OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN SERVICE MARKET EIGHT
YOU'D BE RIGHT THIRTY SEVEN FOR
ME. 30% AFRICAN AMERICAN YOU'D
BE WITH GAP LIKE MINE. AND
THERE WERE IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX. IF WE'VE LEARNED ANYTHING
FROM THE CAN'T QUITE THIS IS A
QUICKLY UPDATE. I HAVE HERE
WITH YOUTHE DATE OF THE GOING
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE A BIGGER
FAN. NOW LET'S THINK ABOUT THE
WORK OF BERMAN. AXIS NO PROBLEM
IF EVER BOB IT'S LONGEST PEOPLE
WITH YOU UP. THAT THE PROBLEM
THE- IT THANK THE FACT TALKING
ABOUT CELEBRATING BACK BERKELEY
IT'S TIME TO DO SOMETHING ACT.
TO MAKE THAT VERY COULD BE MADE.
EIGHT YOU'D BE AMAZED BETTY
RECORD GAVE COLLOQUIUM AND
POLICIES TO CREATE ACCESS TO
JOBS AND THEY'RE BACK WE'VE
BEEN AT WORK. INCLUDING HIRING
BENCHMARK INCLUDES ATHLETE AND
TARGET IT HARD PROBABLY. IT IS
WHAT DID WE THAT I THE INTERIOR
OF THE COURT EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
IRWIN YOUR AVAILABLE VIA PHONE
OR ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. HELLO IRWIN ARE THERE.
IRWIN JUST CHECKING OR EITHER
VIA PHONE. FRENCH PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO TO SIGNAL AN
OPERATOR.
FOR ONE ARE THERE. TO
THE RESPOND TO THAT ARE HIS.
HIS DENYING CAMERON SKI TO
RESCUE. STRESS GARY THERE VIA
PHONE. JUST TRY ONE MORE TIME
ORANGE RED SCARY THERE VIA
PHONE ON A CA FIVE WEBER. ALEX
SEVEN MAY HAVE LOST SOME SOME
HOME. SO WITH THAT SAID WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND GO TO IN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO ARE YOU THERE. LOW.
FIND IS OPEN IT'S JUST NOT
RESPONDING. OKAY WITH THAT SAID
THAT I WOULD JUST GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO THE NON MAIN
WITNESSES WHO WANT TO PROVIDE-
TESTIMONY. REMIND YOUR FOR YOUR
NOT SPEAKING- TO MEET YOUR
PHONE. ARE ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION WHAT
THAT WILL MOVE ON TO IN PERSON
ANYONE HERE WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
REMEMBER JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. MAYBE
I'M SUPPOSED. WE'VE BEEN TRYING
FOR ACTION. FROM YEAH THANK.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN PERSON.
SAY NONE WILL GONE VIA VIDEO
ANYBODY VIA VIDEO WHO WOULD
LIKE TO STATE THEIR NAME
OBSERVATION POSITION ON A CA
FIVE. SEE NONE BE A VIDEO HOW
ABOUT VIA PHONE. IS THERE
ANYBODY VIA PHONE WHO LIKE TO
STATE THEIR POSITION ON A CA
FIVE. IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIND
ONE FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING THAT
THE GERMAN BURKE FROM A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE WHITE LOBBY
FOUNDED BY QUAKERS- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU ANYONE NEXT.
YES WILL DOUBLE LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE ONE THREE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY ONE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YOU
THERE LIKE TO PROVIDE YOUR
SUPPORT POSITION ON A CA FIVE.
HEARING NO RESPONSE WILL GO THE
NEXT LINE IN Q. WHICH IS LINE%
FIFTY FIVE POINT FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS MICHELLE
WE'LL I AM FROM SAN DIEGO ASIAN
AMERICANS BUT EQUALITY WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WHO'S NEXT. NEXT WILL BE
LINE NOT BURKE AND THIRTY EIGHT
ONE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THAT COULD
HURT MEMBERS BECAUSE KEVIN
BAKER FOR THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF CLIFORNIANS
TRONG SUPPORTED EACH YEAR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHO DO WE
HAVE NEXT. NEXT UP WILL BE LINE
TWENTY FOUR LINE TWENTY FOUR
BUT YOU'RE AN ADULT BUT. HELLO
EVERYONE HM. YES WE CAN HEAR
THE- HELLO UNDER SECTION THE CO
FOUNDER AND HELLO I DON'T THE
BRANCHES OF THE AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF AMERICANS LIKE
QUALITY- WOULD REPRESENT
SEVENTY HAGEN MEMBERS. WITH
QUALITY OF HOPE AND A JEW TO
VOTE NO ON THE SHOULD. AT FIFTY
IF YOU ARE. I THANK YOU WHO IS
NOW. SEXUAL GOT WIND OF ONE
TWENTY ONE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CANNOT HEAR
ME YES. HI EVERYBODY KEEP I
WANT TO RETIRE HERE MAY IS THIS
IMMENSELY. RESCUE CAN YOU HOLD
FOR A SECOND WE'LL GET BACK TO
YOU. OF COURSE I'M GLAD YOU CAN
HEAR ME. OKAY WHO DO WE HAVE
THE STATE THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION POSITION. GO AHEAD.
HI AT MY- MY NAME IS MARY DOWN
AND FROM SAN DIEGO AND I AM A
GUMMY- COLD- THIS BILL EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE AND A WILL OR
TO COLLECT MORE THAN. TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT AS LONG BONTA THE NEXT
RECORD. CAROL THE FROM LINE ONE
ZERO SIX ONE ZERO SIX ZERO AN
INSULT. HELLO PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME REGISTRATION CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR ME. YES I WONDER THE-
YES GRANT WELL OKAY BUT MY NAME
IS BEYOND THEM AND A LOT OF
THEM DON'T SAN DIEGO. BUT IN MY
FAMILY. THIS WEEKEND. JOHN IS
OPPOSED. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE I
WANT MY KIDS TO BE. DONE BY THE
QUALITY THAT NOT BY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT SPEAKER. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE'LL GO TO LAW I AM
FIFTY SEVEN LINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME CAN CAN I'M REPRESENTING
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND FAMILY
IN SAN JOSE. AND WHEN WE ARE
SICK WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
DOCTORS WHO GOT INTO THEIR
MEDICAL OR BECAUSE OF THEIR
HARD WORK AND TAX ALLEGE.
BECAME DOCTORS BECAUSE THEY
WERE FORTY QUALIFY ENOUGH FOR
MOST DEAL FOR YOU ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER. NEXT
BIG CORPORATE LINE ONE FIFTY TO
ONE FIFTY TO OPEN. GOOD MORNING
ANDREA RIVERA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONE TO THE NEXT BIGGER.
EXPECT RURAL BEELINE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
ANDREAS SOME MODE OPPOSE. THANK
YOU FOR COMMON SMART THE NEXT
FIGURE BACK BLINDNESS. NEXT
SPEAKER IS ONE FORTY THREE.
HELLO EVERYONE IS OPEN. OKAY
HEAR ME YES. LOW YES THAT ARE
THIS IS A FIVE ONE FOR THIRTY
YEARS AGO- I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHAT THE NEXT FIGURE BACK WILL
BE LOCKED NINE THIRTY NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YOU THERE AND WHAT EITHER.
CHECK OUT LINE FOR IT. HELLO I
HAVE HEAR ME YES. THE U. M.
FROM THE NECK- CHINESE AMERICAN
WITH MY TWO LOVELY KAY'S SO I'M
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IT'S THE BEST ALL HARD WORK NOT
THANK YOU FOR COMING THIS MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT BIGGER. NEXT
DEADLINE FIFTY LINE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. YES STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION MISSION.
IS THE FARM I ONLY A POST.
THANK YOU THE NEXUS LINE ONE
TWENTY THREE ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MONEY
AND LET THE DENTIST JOHN
CALLING FROM WITHIN THE A GOAL-
I'D DONE IT OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MORE ON TO THE NEXT
WEEK. NEXT DEADLINE. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN ONE SIX SEVEN. HELLO THIS
IS A MURDER SURE KILL I'M NOT
IN A LEADERSHIP POSITION ON A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS GONNA
STICK COMMUNITY AFFECT EACH
TUNE I STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT FOR THE
NEXT BAKER. THANK SPEAKER
APPLYING SIXTY FIVE LINES SIXTY
FIVE. HI MY NAME IS CINDY AYE
SHAY AND PUT BRING FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA- FIRST I
WANTED TO SAY THAT THE CHINESE
AMERICAN FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
THE- CAN. DOES NOT AGREE PLEASE
SEND ME TO WHAT I TO BASED ON
MY OWN MERITS INSTEAD OF MY
SKIN KERR THEIR SECOND THING I
WANT TO SAY IS IF YOU WANT TO
OVERTURN A VOTE JUST FOR YOUR
POSITION ARE YOU FOR OR AGAINST.
THANK YOU FOR A COMBINATION OF
ON TO THE NEXT BIGGER. NEXT
WEEK EARLY LINE SEVENTY SIX
LINE SEVENTY SIX. ONE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE CHECK YOUR LINE FOR
THE NEXT SPEAKER IS LINE ONE
FORTY ONE FOUR ZERO. HELLO GOOD
MORNING YES GO AHEAD. YEAH YEAH
TRY NAY OPPOSE THIS BILL IS THE
TWENTY FIFTH CREATE MORE
REGULAR DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
RACE KILL BY THANK YOU FOR
COMING THIS EVENING ONE TO THE
NEXT WEEK OR- SPEAKER IS LINE
FIFTY FOUR LINE FIFTY FOUR. IS
THAT THE LINK SO BOMB THIRTY
DEEPLY I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED BUT
IT'S STILL. THANK YOU FOR
COMMON THIS MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER. NEXT BAKER LIMA. ONE
FORTY SEVEN ONE FOUR SEVEN. THE
MORNING HONESTLY FROM THE EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY CONCRETE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER. NEXT SPEAKER LINE ONE
FIFTY ONE LINE ONE FIFTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING ERICA ROMERO ON
BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BAKER.
THAT LINE. ONE FORTY ONE ONE
FOUR ONE. GOOD MORNING AT HOME
OTHER THAN WHAT THE WHITE IN
MIRROR PARK WITH A NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING THIS MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT BAKER. NEXT
SPEAKER IS LINE. ONE FIFTEEN
ONE ONE FIVE. THE MORNING THIS
IS THE WEATHER TOO CLEVER BILL
CLINTON'S STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR COMING LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER. CAROLINE. ONE
FORTY TWO ONE FOUR TWO. YES
GOOD MORNING THIS IS NEED TO
LOW DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF OAKLAND WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR COMMENTS MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT BIGGER. BACK SPEAKER LINE.
ONE EIGHTY THREE ONE EIGHT
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MY VALLEY KINCAID I MAKE
CONSTITUENTS OF KEN COOLEY IS
LIVING IN ARDEN ARCADE AND I AM
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
COMING MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BIGGER. THANK SPEAKERS LINE.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVEN
FIVE. I'M MUCH TOO I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO AND STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER. THANK MAKERS FIND. ONE
SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO. HI MY NAME
IS JENNIFER SAYING I'M A
RESIDENT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
I ALSO REPRESENT THE ASIAN
AMERICAN BLOG WE APPROPRIATE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
COMING. ONE TO THE NEXT BIGGER.
THERE ARE MORE IN Q. HOWEVER WE
DO NOT HAVE LINE NUMBERS FROM
THEM YET AT THIS TIME WE NEED A
FEW MOMENTS TO CATCH UP THE
QUEUE. IN FRONT. EIGHTY
CHAIRMAN THE SISTER WENT TO
READ CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YOU
KNOW GO AHEAD AND- GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR TRANSFORM JUST REMIND
YOU OF THREE MINUTES THANK YOU
GOD. OF COURSE THANK YOU I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES EARLIER MY NAME IS
WHEN CHAMBER AND SKI AND DEAN
AND JEFF PH CHOPPER
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR OF LAW
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW I'VE
SEEN AND STUDIED THE VERY
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS PROPOSITION
TWO OH NINE. IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE I WAS APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS TO SERVE ON
THE COMMISSION OF THE PERSON
OUT BEACH THE WAY TO
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR I CHAIR THE
COMMISSION LOS ANGELES CITY
CONTRACTING THE CONSIDER THESE
ISSUES IN THE LAST TWELVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN THE DEAN OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA LAW
SCHOOL. I WANT TO MAKE THREE
POINTS. FIRST POSITION TO NINE
OF THE NECESSARY. BECAUSE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW ALREADY DELIVERY LIMITS
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. SECOND
PROPOSITION TO AN END OF THE
DESIRABLE BECAUSE UNLIKE THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION
ELIMINATES AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
EVEN WHEN IT'S NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE A COMPELLING PURPOSE.
AND IT DOES HAVE A DEVASTATING
EFFECT ON DIVERSITY INVOLVING
DISCRIMINATION CALIFORNIA.
FINALLY PROPOSITION TWO A NIGHT
OF FUN WITH HERE KEEPING PHAM
SPECIALLY PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
WOMEN TO USE IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS OF THESE CAN. AS TO THE
FIRST POINT THE SUPREME COURT
REPEAL IS HELD THAT AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION PROGRAMS. SCRUTINY UNDER
THE EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE OF
THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT. IT'S
RIGOROUS TESTS REQUIRED
PERMITTED ACTION PROGRAMS
DISTURBING THAT THE CHIEF A
COMPELLING INTEREST. IN OTHER
WORDS THEY'RE ALREADY
SIGNIFICANT LIMITS ON
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION BY
GOVERNMENT WITHOUT PROP TWO
NINE. SECOND PROPOSITION TWO
NINE THAT MUCH FURTHER THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION.
BANNING AFFIRMATIVE ACTION EVEN
WHEN IT'S NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
A COMPELLING PURPOSE. THE
RESULT OF THE WIN REMEDIES FOR
PAST DISCRIMINATION AND FOR
EFFORT TO DIVERSITY. FOR
EXAMPLE BUT AGAIN I STATE
CONSTITUTION COLLEGE MAY USE
RACE AND SEX IS ONE OF MANY
FACTORS IN THIS IS. NOT
CALIFORNIA THE PROPOSITION
NINE. STUDY AFTER STUDY SHOWS
THE UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR. IN CONTRAST TO
THE GOVERNMENT EMPLOYMENT. AND
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
TWO OH NO FOR THE PARTICULAR
DEVASTATING EFFECT BUT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. ALL
STUDIES SHOW THAT MINORITY
GROUPS STOP FOR. AFRICAN
AMERICANS BUT MAX ASIAN
AMERICAN AND NATIVE AMERICANS
WHEN AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS
LIMITED. FINALLY EFFECTIVE
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE IS TO
KEEP SOME GROUPS ESPECIALLY
RACIAL MINORITIES AND WOMEN
FROM USING THE POLITICAL SYSTEM
WELL THIS CAN'T. ANY OTHER
GROUP CAN APPEAL THE STATE
LEGISLATURE BUT CITY COUNCIL
BUT COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
PREVENTATIVE TREATMENT. BUT
THOSE DESIRING AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION ARE UNIQUELY BARRED FROM
USING THE POLITICAL SYSTEM THAT
IS WHY TOUCH FELT HENDERSON
DECLARED PROPOSITION TWO AND I
TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT THE
RULING WAS OVER RULED BY THE
NINTH CIRCUIT. OPPOSITION TO A
NINE IS AN EXPERIMENT NOW FOR
QUITE OF A CENTURY. IT IS
TREMENDOUSLY POWERFUL FOR
DIVERSITY AND QUALITY.
DIVERSITY INEQUALITY IN
CALIFORNIA. I URGE THE PASSAGE
OF THE ACA FIVE. THANK YOU AND
WITH THAT WE'LL GO BACK TO OUR-
OUR OF MEMBERS OF VIA PHONE- DO
WE HAVE FOLKS READY TO PROVIDE
THEIR POSITION STATE THEIR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION. YES LINE ONE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE FOUR THREE. HELLO YOU'RE
THERE BY ONE FORTY THREE.
HEARING NO RESPONSE WILL GO TO
THE NEXT CALLER THE NEXT ONE IN
Q. IS LINE FORTY SEVEN LINE
FORTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS TIFFANY JONES I AM A
RESIDENT OF BELOW CALIFORNIA
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT ACA
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
COMING NEXT BIGGER. THANK WILL
NOT GO TO THE LINE OF. ONE
TWENTY SIX ONE TWO SIX. HELLO
MY NAME IS A CHANGE CHIANG I'M
A FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-
ASIAN AMERICANS I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE
WHICH WILL BE COVERED LIKE
EVERY COMMON THIS MOVE TO THE
NEXT BAKER. NEXT SPEAKER IS
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND TEN THAT'S
TWO ONE ZERO. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR OVER THE YEARS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MANUAL BUT HE GETS ON BEHALF OF
THE EDUCATION TRUST WHAT.
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE IN ALLOWING THIS TO GO
BEFORE THE VOTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT OUR
NEXT SPEAKER. X. MAKERS LINE
ONE SIXTY FOUR ONE SIX FOUR.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS LILIA COLIN I'M A MEMBER
ELECTED MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION I'M CALLING TO.
REGISTER MY FULL SUPPORT FOR A
BI A FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR COMING NEXT BAKER. NEXT AS
FAR LINE TWO TWO SEVEN THAN
THAT TWO TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS THERE A LITTLE
THEIR LOWEST EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR KIDS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT ACA FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
COMING NEXT WEEK. THANK SPEAKER
IS LINE AT TWO OO EIGHT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT. MY NAME IS A
TERM MEMBERS SCRIPTED RESPONSE
WITH CHIRLA OF THE COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS A
STRONG SUPPORTER THE C. FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT
BIGGER. EXPECT HER IS LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR THAT
TWO THREE FOUR WHICH- IT WILL
BE IN A COUPLE OF THE DIFFERENT
ALL RIGHT NOW. NOT AT THE
BEGINNING OF WHAT THE PROBLEM.
CAN YOU WHICH ARE FROM. HELLO.
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS ONE OF DOT
ORG. HELLO ARE YOU THERE FOR
THE POSITION STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION MEETING TOMORROW.
TICKETS ON YOUR KNOWLEDGE I
THINK IT'S AN ELIGIBLE WILL GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE NEXT LINE
WHICH IS TO SIXTEEN TO ALL SIX.
HELLO ARE YOU THERE FIND TO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIXTEEN YES STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IT WAS THE SECOND.
HELLO THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
FOR MORE ON. THE ONLY
ACCORDINGLY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT BIGGER. SPEAKER IS
LYING TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO THREE ZERO. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS HOW YOU
SHOULD BROWN I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AFRICAN AMERICAN POCKET
EXPANDED STRONG SUPPORT OF A-
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE. ONE
TWO TWO ONE. HI THIS IS TAMMY
I'M CALLING FROM AREA ON THE
WHOLE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE IT IS
DISCRIMINATING THANK YOU FOR.
THE NEXT RECORD AND AT AGE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE NEXT
LINE WHICH IS TWO HUNDRED AND.
THIRTY EIGHT TWO THREE EIGHT.
HI THIS IS NEARLY NEVER MERITS
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. THANK
YOU FOR COMING NEXT SPEAKER.
SPEAKER IS LYING TO HER PARDON
BUT TWO THREE TWO TWO THREE. I
THINK YOU CAN MEMBERS PLANNING
WE THE CHAIR AND I'M THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER AT
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA WEARING
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE BECAUSE ASIAN AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN NEARLY AS MUCH JOB
LOSS AS THE LATIN THAT
COMMUNITY THE RETIREMENT OF
THAT NATURE. THANK SPEAKER IS
FROM LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE TWO ONE TWO. HELLO ARE
YOU THERE. ALL OF YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HELLO THAT MIGHT BE
JENNIFER LEO I'M FROM I'M
CALLING FROM DUBLIN CALIFORNIA
I- STRONGLY OPPOSE AC A FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT
WEEK. SPEAKER SOMEONE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT ONE SIX
EIGHT. MORNING MY NAME IS AMY I
THE CALIFORNIA THEM AT THE END
OF I HAVE BECOME A- PARTY
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE I STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FIVE ANNIE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME COMMITTEE. THANKS FOR
COMING NEXT BAKER. WHAT I
PLEASE. HELLO YOU THERE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE FOR HANDING OFF.
ONE ONE FIVE NINE OF THE NEXT
QUESTION ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MAY
HURDLE YOU ALL I'M WITH THE
EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY IN
OAKLAND AND I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU FOR COMING NEXT SPEAKER.
SECOND IN LINE FIFTY NINE FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI HELLO
YES. YES STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IN A POSITION. ALL
RIGHT MY NAME IS FAR FROM.
CALIFORNIA I JUST HOPE OF DON'T
WORRY ASIAN AMERICANS FROM ANY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WE HAVE
WHICH ALL AMERICAN AMERICAN
THANK YOU FOR A MOMENT LET'S
MOVE ON. IN A LOT OF AMERICANS
SO. WE GIVE LOCAL LINE TWO- OH
THREE TWO ZERO THREE. EDDIE
HUANG IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT
WEEK. TWO FIVE TO SIXTY FIVE.
ONE TO SIXTY FIVE MEET YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVEON CHRIS
BROWN CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR COMING NEXT BIGGER. LINE
ONE FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO. HI
THIS IS ANTHONY CHAVEZ CALLING
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT BIGGER. TWO FORTY
TWO. HI THIS IS STEPHANIE ON
FIRST GENERATION CHINESE
IMMIGRANT IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT BIGGER.
TELECOM FROM LINE ONE FORTY
NINE ONE FOUR NINE. HI THIS IS
NATALIE RECALL LONG I LOVE SO
CAN FOR DISCO RESIDENT AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT BIGGER. THAT COMES
FLYING. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
TWO SIX EIGHT. HI THIS ONE AWAY
AS HE ASIAN AMERICAN COALITION
FOR EDUCATION REPRESENTS A TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ASIAN AMERICAN
OF INACTION. NATIONWIDE THANKS
STRONG OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT BIGGER. COMES FROM
ONE NINETY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MARIAH
COCHRAN OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT BAKER.
LINE TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TO LEARN A THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YOU
THERE MOVEON BLIND TO THE-
THIRTY THREE CAN YOU HEAR
MOVEON YES MEXICAN THANK YOU
TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY LARA CALLING FROM
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT
BIGGER. THAT COMES FROM NINE TO
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL ROOM I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF SILICON VALLEY
CHINESE AT THAT THE MISSION
FOUNDATION WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND GRASSROOTS NUMBERS.
EIGHT INTEL CANAL EACH OF THE
CHINESE AMERICAN HERITAGE AND
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
A FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT NEXT SPEAKER. LINE
ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JANELLE WONG
CHINESE AMERICAN PROGRESSIVE
ACTION AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT
BIGGER. PINE TO EIGHTY TWO TWO
EIGHT TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SCOTT MCFEELY I'M
COVERING THE CALIFORNIAI'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT
BIGGER. LINE. TWO EIGHTY FOUR
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR. HELLO
THE NINE THIRTY FOR YOU ON MUTE.
HELLO THERE WILL MOVE ON MOVE
ON. THANK YOU FOR FLYING TO
THIRTEEN THREE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS CHRIS FOR SHOCK LARA
AND AN ASIAN AMERICAN MOM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I AM A MOM
OF YOU DON'T HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND- STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT WEEK.
THANK SPEAKERS LINE TO- FOR TWO
HUNDRED FOUR. HI BUT JOHNSON
WITH CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF ACA FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
COMING NEXT BAKER. LINE TWO
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING DOCTOR CHRIS NOW I'M
I'M NOT A RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FROM IMPERIAL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT
BIGGER. LINE TWO EIGHTY ONE. I
CAN HEAR ME OF THAT. OKAY YES
STATE YOUR NAME HI MY NAME IS
TANYA THANK. GO AHEAD PERFECT
MY NAME IS YVONNE MCKENNA. MY
NAME IN THE LONG RUN YEAH AND
I'M CALLING EXPRESSED STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MEDI. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT NEXT WEEK. LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR THREE
ZERO FOUR. LOVE THE MONEY IT
AND YOU HADN'T CUTTING FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA STATE THE
TECHNICAL ASIAN MARKET CAN FIVE
COPY WEIGHT DONNIE OPPOSED TO
TWO EIGHT EIGHT FIVE EIGHT LIKE
A COMPANION. FOR YOUR ID CODE
MOTORIST BEATEN. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY THE YEAR WELL
CALIFORNIA I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO TREAT IT A BIG FIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR COMMENT NEXT BIGGER.
THAT COMES FROM LINE TO NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ERIN APTIOM A CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY AMPLE FROM CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ACA FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT
BIGGER. WE DO HAVE ABOUT A
DOZEN STILL IN Q. BOOK ONLINE
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX YOUR OPEN.
HELLO THERE. HELLO HELLO. HELLO
YES YOU HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL. AT HIM YOU HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL FOR
AGAINST. HELLO LET ME ALL YES
IS THERE. YES AVE I HATE THAT I
CAN MORNING AFTER MONEY COUNTY
ALABAMA AND WE ARE LOOKING FOR
THE COMBAT IT AND I DON'T
OPPOSING THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
COMMITTED GOING TO THE VALUE
ADDED BY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT BIGGER.
NEXT COMMUNISTS ONLINE THREE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE ONE FOUR. HELLO THERE.
HELLO. THIS FOR THE NEXT BAKER.
THANK YOU THAT COMES ON LINE.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE TWO
THREE NINE. HELLO THERE LINE TO
THIRTY NINE THERE. HELLO. MOVE
THE NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU THAT
COMES FROM LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
ONE FOUR EIGHT. YEAH CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY NOW-
CORPORATE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT BAKER. THE FINE.
TO FORTY ONE TWO FOUR ONE.
WELCOME OF FLORA CALLING THE
TRUMP SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR COMING NEXT BIGGER.
LINE TWO TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO TWO ZERO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ALL MY NAME IS
CAROLYN SALAR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR DOCTOR GEORGE
MCKENNA L. U. S. T. SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF A THREE EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR COMMENT NEXT
BAKER. LINE THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN THREE TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE TWENTY
WALL AND BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
EXPECTING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
COMMON NEXT SPEAKER. THANK YOU
LINE THREE TO SIX THREE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS NICOLE THEIR THING I'M
CALLING FROM LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE WE'RE JUST ASKING
YOU TO LET THE VOTERS DECIDE IN
ADVANCE THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU FOR COMING NEXT BIGGER. EX
COMMUNIST LINE TO THREE THREE
TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STE. HELLO THERE WELL YES. IT
YES STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. HI I'M
A QUICK THING I'M FROM-
CALIFORNIA- BAY AREA AND I'M
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED THE SPEED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT
SPEAKER. THANK YOU LINE. THREE
THIRTY ONE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE. HELLO YES IS THERE A GOOD
MORNING I AM VERY I'M DEREK A
FROM- PER MONTH CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSED BY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
NEXT SPEAKER. LINE. THREE TO
FIVE THREE TWENTY FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS DANNY I'M I'M FROM
CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO I
STRONGLY AGAINST IT'S A FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT
SPEAKER. I'M FROM LINE TWO ZERO
TWO. RESULT YEAH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FACULTY AT THE
STATION A CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
FIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
NEXT SPEAKER. NEXT MAKERS LINE
TWO SIX SIX TO SIXTY SIX OPEN
PLEASE. HELLO THERE. BOTH HELLO
THERE. HELLO MORNING BUT ME YES
GO AHEAD MORNING. STATE YOUR
NAME IN YOUR POSITION. MY NAME
IS DAN AGAIN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE THREE EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT BAKER. EX
COMMUNISTS FROM THREE ELEVEN
THREE ONE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JESSE FAMILY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT NEXT BAKER. LINE
THREE FORTY THREE FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ONE OF
THE AUTUMN OF BOB ON BOTH ON.
FOUGHT FOR ALL THE EIGHT BALL.
THANK YOU FOR COMING EXPECTING.
LINE THREE FOURTEEN THREE ONE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALLER ON
LINE THREE FOURTEEN ARE YOU
THERE. HELLO. HELLO ARE YOU
THERE. FOR THE NEXT BAKER.
THANK YOU LINE. TWO SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN ZERO HI THIS IS MIKE
AROUND- I'M CALLING FROM SAN
DIEGO I'M A NURSE AYE AYE
STRONG- ANYA JUMPED OPPOSITION
UP THIS IS THE BY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT BAKER. BY
AND. THREE FORTY THREE THREE
FOUR THREE. HI EVERYONE- MY
NAME IS CODY A GAME AND I AM
THE CORRECT THERE AND LONG INTO
THE POLITICS- I'M NOT AGAINST
SACRAMENTO AND BY NOW AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE. THREE
TWO THREE THREE TWENTY THREE.
HI MY NAME IS TERRY SNYDER- I'M
A LECTURE AT BERKLEE SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- I SEE THE
STUDENTS ALL THE TIME WE NEED
TO HAVE ALL OF THE BRAIN POWER
OF CALIFORNIA. UNLEASHED AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANKS FOR YOUR COMMENT SPEAKER
FOLEY. FIND ONE NINETY TWO ONE
NINE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS NICOLE CONCERT SHE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATE AND SHE DOES BEEN
CRACKED EDUCATIONAL
ORGANIZATION BUT ACTUALLY
MISSING FROM THE COMMITTEE ON
THE OFFICE FOR CALLING IN FOR
THE FIGHT. THE FACT. THANK YOU
FOR COMING NEXT BIGGER. NINE
THREE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT WAS THREE FIVE FOUR.
HELLO YOU THERE. HELLO YOU
THERE. NEXT BIGELOW WELL YES.
YES I CAN HEAR YOU HI MY NAME
IS. IF I'M RUNNING A RESIDENTS
AND SECOND GENERATION AMERICAN.
ON I JOLLY EIGHTEEN I. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT YEAR. LINE.
THREE THREE THREE THREE THIRTY
THREE HI HI JOE I'M CALLING
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AN
ACCOUNTANT AT THE COMPLETION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE NEXT
FIGURE. LINE. THREE FORTY FOUR
THREE FOUR FOUR. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY HI SORRY
THANKS MY NAME IS A MUSLIM AND
I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO ON A
BUS GENERATION IMMIGRANTS HAVE
A DAUGHTER IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
ZERO FIVE- HOPE YOU CAN SELECT
THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
I NEXT WEEK. A LINE THREE FOUR
EIGHT THREE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN YEARS
FROM THE TO CALIFORNIA NINE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE STATE I
THINK IT. NEXT BAKER. THREE
FOUR FIVE ONE HUNDRED THREE
FOUR FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL M. I'M A PHARMACIST IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR COMING NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU
LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS EBONY AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE DIVERSITY AND
LEADERSHIP AND- MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION WHICH INCLUDE
EDUCATION QUITE PARTNER ENERGY
PROVIDERS AND INNOVATE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TEACH FOR AMERICA LA.
AND UNITED NEGRO COLLEGE FUND
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
COMING NEXT BIGGER. LINE. THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE THREE THREE
NINE. EVEN PATTERSON I WAS
ADMITTED TO UC BERKELEY LAW
SCHOOL UNDER AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
PASSED THE BY THE FIRST TIME
I'M STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF ACA
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT WEEK. LINE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO TWO SIX TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JASON HSU THE PREPARATION
TENANTS AMERICAN. DUE TO THE
LACK OF THE IMPACT ON JOBS WILL
ASIAN AMERICAN. I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
SPEAKER. LINE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE THREE FIVE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS A
MEDICAL DENTAL CARE OF FROM A
CYNICAL I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE US
EIGHTY FIVE BECAUSE THE- THANK
YOU FOR THE SUMMIT NEXT BIGGER.
LINE. THREE SIX THREE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE. HELLO HI
MY NAME IS THE WHOLE BOOK
ACCORDING TO JOHNNIE APPROACH
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT FIGURE.
FIND ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE SEVEN SEVEN. HELLO
YES GO AHEAD HELLO YES NO WAY
IDEALLY IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE- REALLY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT BAKER.
LINE THREE THREE EIGHT THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO YES GO
AHEAD HELLO. THE NAME CHANGE
FROM CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING NEXT
SPEAKER. NINE THREE SEVENTY ONE
THREE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YOU THERE. HELLO.
THEY DISCONNECTED NEXT IN LINE
THREE SEVENTY FOUR. YEAH HI.
YES GO AHEAD HOW MANY YES- YEAH
I'M FOND OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND PUT THAT YOU KNOW FOR A
LONG TIME AND PHD IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND I'M LOOKING
ARCHITECT IN MY COMPANY AND I
WOULD STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHT
ZERO FIVE IT'S UNFAIR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT
BIGGER. OUR. THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO THREE SIX TWO. HI MY
NAME IS A DOLLARS- I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
STATE YEAH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT BIGGER. LINE THREE
SEVENTY THREE SEVEN ZERO. HI MY
NAME IS LILLIAN CLAN AND I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT BIGGER.
FIND THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
CAROLINA'S OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS THE DIVISION AND THE REST OF
THE CALIFORNIA I DON'T OPPOSE A
DAY BYE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR COMING NEXT BIGGER. FIND
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MATT I'M A
FIRST GENERATION INDIAN THAT
LIVING IN OAKLAND AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORTED A STATE BY
WE SHOULD LET THE VOTERS DECIDE
BUT THE SCOPE OF WORK THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR COMING. NEXT
BIGGER. LINE THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE THREE EIGHT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI IF WE CAN
DE AFFIRMATIVE YEAH GO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY- OPERATED
AT THE CENTER MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR COMING NEXT BIGGER. LINE.
THREE HUNDRED FORTY ONE THREE
FOUR ONE. HI MY NAME IS JANE
LYLE LOCAL CALIFORNIA
PERSPIRATION TRANSAMERICAN- I
STRONGLY SUPPORT BUT THE BALLOT
THE VOTER'S BUT BUT THANK YOU
FOR COMING NEXT WEEKEND. LINE
THREE EIGHT EIGHT THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JACOB TARA MAURICE AND
GRADUATE AND AN ARTIST AN
ORGANIZER FOR FREMONT
CALIFORNIA AND I'M STRONGLY IN
ORDER IS A FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT NEXT WEEK. LINE.
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE THREE
EIGHT NINE. HI MOM ACCORDING
FROM ILLEGAL- ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
NEXT BAKER. I AM. THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR THREE SIX FOUR. HI
MY NAME IS ALEX SMITH AND FROM
THE LOS ANGELES AREA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT FIVE. THANK
YOU FOR COMING NEXT RICHARD.
LINE. THREE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
THREE NINE FOUR. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
GO AHEAD CAN YOU HEAR ME YES I
HAD A RAGING THAT MADE I'M A
RETIRED CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT NEXT
BIGGER. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHER COMMENTS IN Q. OKAY
WITH THAT SAID WILL BRING IT
BACK UP TO COMMITTEE. ANY
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BUT FIRST WANT TO
COMMENT ABOUT HOW I JUST LOVE
THE DIVERSE THE OF THE PHONE
CALLS FOR AND AGAINST- THIS A
CA FIVE. I THINK THAT THAT'S
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S DROUGHT
BARBER CITY. HAVE EVERYBODY
INCLUDED IN EVERYTHING THAT WE
DO. THERE WERE A FEW COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE THE THAT I
WANTED TO JUST EMPHASIZE ARE WE
ONE OF THE LETTERS OF SUPPORT
CAME FROM SO MANY OF OUR-
ORGANIZATIONS TRUST WORST.
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE ASIAN LONG ALLIANCE
WORKING FOR DIGNITY JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY. AND THAT SOME OF
THOSE THAT I'VE WORKED WITH FOR
SO MANY YEARS LIKE PASTOR ST
CASEY WITH COPE. AFTER ENTERING
YOUR FOR THIS PRESIDENT CEO OF
PARK. OUR DOCTOR WHO SECOND
THAT ON BUT FROM THE LATINO
LATINO ROUNDTABLE THE CHINESE
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION VINCENT
TO PANDA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE
INVOLVEMENT OF SO MANY IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR THIS PARTICULAR.
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT BUT MY
FIRST QUESTION IS TO THE AUTHOR
I DO WANT TO CONFIRM. THE VOTE
FOR THIS. IS NOT OVER TURNING
TO NIGHT IT IS ALLOWING THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO VOTE ON IT IS
THAT CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT
THIS IS TO PUT IT ON THE BALLOT
SO THAT THE VOTERS CAN DECIDE
WHETHER WE WANT TO CONTINUE
DOWN THE SAME PATH OR GO BACK
AND DO WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE
PAST WITH AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
THANK YOU. IN THE LETTER FROM
THE THIS ORGANIZATION THERE ARE
A FEW QUOTES THAT IF I MAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THEY SAY OVER
TURNING AND I QUOTE OVERTURNING
CALIFORNIA'S BAN ON PROGRAMS
THAT PROMOTE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
IS LONG OVERDUE. THE GROWING
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
HARM OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ONLY HEIGHTENS THE
IMPORTANCE OF BRINGING FAIRNESS
FOR PUBLIC CONTRACTING AND
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES. LATER IN
THE LETTER THEY SAY WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO DENY CALIFORNIANS.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF HOW THEY LOOK
OR WHO THEY ARE. THIS
PARTICULAR- ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT WILL
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD AND
ALLOW ALL CALIFORNIANS TO FIND
A GOOD JOB- TO JUST DECENT WAGE
AND GET AHEAD IN LIFE AND IN
THEIR CAREERS. YOU CAN'T HAVE
SHARED SUCCESS WITHOUT SHARED
OPPORTUNITY LET'S PUT
CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TOWARD
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL.
WITHOUT A DOUBT WHEN WE HAVE
DIVERSE CITY THAT IS WHEN WE OF
CALIFORNIANS WILL BENEFIT IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE ADVERSITY WE ALL
LOSE WE ALL LOSE. I'D LIKE TO
BELIEVE AND I'M SURE MANY OF US
WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S COLORBLIND. BUT
THAT'S NOT WHERE WE ARE. AND
THE IT WAS. IF WE DON'T ALLOW
PEOPLE TO BEGIN WITH THE LET
LEVEL A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO SUCCEED AT
INCREASING THE DIVERSITY THAT
WE ABSOLUTELY NEED THIS DIVERSE
CITY IS GOING TO MAKE WHAT WILL
BE MORE REFLECTIVE OF WHAT THE
STATE REALLY LOOKS LIKE. AND
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED HERE
IN THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ME IS
THAT IS JUST SO MANY OTHERS. I
DO WANT TO. END WITH A QUOTE
FROM A GREAT FRIEND. WHO
HAPPENS TO BE THE AUTHOR OF
THIS. CALIFORNIANS HAVE BUILT
THE FIFTH THE LARGEST AND
STRONGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
BUT TOO MANY HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AND NOT SHARING IN
OUR STATES PROSPERITY
PARTICULARLY WOMEN. FAMILIES OF
COLOR AND LOW WAGE WORKERS
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING TO CORRECT THE
HARM THAT WAS DONE IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE
THAT PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DESERVE THE RIGHT.
TO DETERMINE WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE WITH PROP TWENTY NINE AND
WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU I THINK THAT
ALSO SUMMER VOEPEL AND THEN
SUMMER COOPER WITH COMMON GUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME. EDUCATING EACH OTHER. BUT
I THINK I WAS EDUCATED MORE SO
I WOULD LIKE TO STATE MY
POSITION HERE. AND MY LOGICAL
REASONS. FIRST OF ALL I HAVE
ANALYZE THIS IN MY OWN MIND ON
A POLITICAL LEVEL A MORAL LEVEL
IN AND ECONOMIC LEVEL. AND IT
OCCURRED TO ME IT THIS PROP TWO
OH NINE WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX CORRECT OKAY. IT
OCCURRED TO ME THAT'S ONE BIT
BUT GOAL GENERATION AGO. ONE
WHOLE GENERATION IT WAS A
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA THAT WITH
A DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHIC MIX NOW
WHAT WHOA OKAY. GOT THAT ONE.
NOW WE'VE GOT CODED NINETEEN
AND BASICALLY OUR ECONOMIC
BUSES BROKEN DOWN AND EVERYBODY
GOT OFF THE BUS NOW WHEN WE GET
GOING AGAIN WHO'S GOING TO GET
ON THE BUS. AND I'M THINKING.
MY BASS AND YOU'VE HEARD MANY
OF MY BASE ON THE PHONE CALLS.
I I'M NOT HERE ON MY OWN I'M
REPRESENTING MY DISTRICT. BUT
I'M GOING TO VOTE YES FOR THIS
TO LEAVE COMMITTEE BECAUSE THE
NEXT STEP IS THE WHOLE
LEGISLATURE OUGHT AND WILL
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. THAT WILL
GIVE ME TIME TO REACH OUT TO MY
FAITH GROUPS. ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS EVERYBODY WHERE YOU
GUYS AT. AND WE'LL HAVE WITHIN
MY DISTRICT A GOOD DEBATE. AND
THEN I WILL MAKE UP MY MIND OF
HOW TO REPRESENT MY DISTRICT ON
THE FLOOR. SO IT BOILS DOWN TO
ME. THIS IS. GOTTA GO BEFORE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THIS GENERATION. THAT'S IT
THAT'S ALL I GOT THANK YOU SOME
RECOUP YOU KNOW WE VOTE ON A
LOT OF THINGS IN LEGISLATURE
AND IT'S NOT THAT OFTEN YOU TO
SEND SOMETHING BACK TO THE
VOTERS HAVE THE VOTERS VOTE FOR
IT THAT'S THAT'S THE BEST OF
BOTH WORLDS THEY PUT US HERE
AND HAVE A VOTERS IN PART OF IT
MAYBE THE CITY IN GOOD OR BAD
OR INDIFFERENT. IT HAPPENS-
I'VE QUESTION FOR DR WEBBER- WE
A LOT OF FOLKS THAT COMMUNITY
CALL AND WHOSE BENEFIT ME IF I
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW THE
INTERESTING THING IS THAT- WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF AND
IT'S HARD TO TALK THIS THING
OUT. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HISTORY OF. PROP TWO OH NINE
THERE WAS A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION PUT OUT ABOUT
HOW IS GOING TO HURT THE ASIAN
COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
ENROLLMENT IN UNIVERSITIES. AND
ALL OF THE DATA THE MATURE WE
GAVE YOU SHOW THAT IT DID NOT.
IN FACT AGENTS DID BETTER UNDER
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION THAN THEY
DID- WITH UNDER UNDER PROP TWO
OH NINE. OF THE PROP TWO NINE
WAS SOLD AS SOMETHING THAT WAS
GOING TO DEAL WITH THE IT AND
PEOPLE THOUGHT THE UNIVERSITY.
AND WHAT IT DID WAS A DECIMATED
REALLY UP LIKE BUSINESSES WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES AND
CONTRACTING IN THE STATE. WE
SAW CONTRACTING IN SAN DIEGO GO
FROM 40% THE WOMEN MINORITIES
DOWN TO ONE AND TWO PERCENT. AS
IT IS TODAY. AND SO WHAT
HAPPENED WAS WE WERE SOLD A
BILL OF GOODS ABOUT IT THE
UNIVERSITY'S DECIDED THEMSELVES
AND THEY HAVE WORKED VERY HARD
TO WITH. THAT FOR YEARS THE
DIVERSITY IS THE NEXT IT'S
NECESSARY FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT THEY HAVE DEVISED. WAYS TO
TRY TO GET A DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION. WE STILL LAG BEHIND
IN SOME AREAS IN TERMS OF THE
POPULATION. BUT THEY WORK VERY
HARD TO MAKE SURE THEY TRY TO
GET FOLKS IN BUT ASIANS ARE
NOT. FED NOT BENEFITING FROM
PROP TWO OH NINE. THEN I
BENEFITING IN TERMS OF
BUSINESSES AND CONTRACTING. NOT
NOT NOT BENEFITING IN TERMS OF
SCHOOL IN MOBILE. AND SO- AS A
RESULT WHEN WE HAD AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AND THAT'S AN EFFORT TO
BE. SO YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT AT
LEAST OF AFFIRMATIVE EFFORT TO
INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS IS NOT A
QUOTA. IT'S NOT A GUARANTEED.
UP AND AS A RESULT OF THOSE
STATE STANDARDS THERE WERE
GREATER IN MOMENTS OF ASIANS
LATINOS. AND AFRICAN AMERICANS.
VERSUS WHAT WAS AS WELL AS THE
REGULAR STUDENTS THE OF THE
OTHER. THAT WOULD THERE. SO
THEY STILL THERE'S- A CONCEPT
THE THIS IS TO HAPPEN AT. OF
AND YET WHEN YOU DEAL WITH THE-
THE AGENTS FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AND A HOST OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO DRILL DOWN TO
THE DATA. MATERIAL WE'VE GIVEN
THEM. IT IS CLEAR THAT THEY
THAT THERE IS NO NEGATIVE THAT
COMES TO ASIAN POPULATIONS. AS
A RESULT OF IT. AFRICAN
AMERICANS FIGHT HARD FOR THIS
PARTICULAR OPPORTUNITY WITH
BERMAN OF ACTION. AND
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH WE ARE THE
LEAST TO PERMANENT BENEFIT FROM
IT. IN TERMS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE DATA AND THE INFORMATION.
YET WE FIGHT FOR IT. BECAUSE WE
KNOW WHAT'S RIGHT AND WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS
TO BE SUCCESSFUL. MOST OF YOU
GOT THE BOSTON GLOBE ARTICLE
CONCERNING. COLVIN WE'RE
TALKING BACK PULL BUT NOW. THE
GROUPS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
DEVASTATED BY COLE WAS AT BUT
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN. AT THE
IMPACT OF IT IN TERMS OF
HEALTH. ECONOMICS ALL OF THOSE
THINGS IT EDUCATION. OUR
CHILDREN WHO ARE WHO ARE STILL
SUFFERING WILL HAVE WITH GREAT
OF LOSS AS A RESULT OF WHAT
WHAT'S GOING ON. IN FEW
RESOURCES TO REBUILD. OUR
BUSINESS IS GOING TO BE
DECIMATED BECAUSE I PEOPLE OF
THE LAST ONE TO GET LOANS AT.
BANKS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
STABILIZE OUR BUSINESSES. AND
WITHOUT GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS
BUT BUSINESS YOU IT'S DIFFICULT
TO STABILIZE A BUSINESS. SO
WHEN YOU BEGIN TO LOOK AT IT
AND SOME SAY WHAT WE SHOULD DO
THIS BECAUSE OF COLD BUT- WE
ARE GOING TO SUFFER THE MOST IS
THE RESULT OF IT AND WITHOUT
SOME AFFIRMATIVE EFFORT WHICH
THE BOSTON GLOBE. TALKED ABOUT.
IT THESE BUSINESS WILL
BUSINESSES WILL NOT COME BACK.
AND THE INTERESTING THING IS
THAT WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT IN
BOSTON THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
DOING SOME AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN. IT'S A
SPECIAL CONTRACTS THE
BUSINESSES AND OTHERS.
CALIFORNIA UNDER PROP TWO OH
NINE CANNOT DO THAT. AND SO WE
WILL SEE IN CALIFORNIA EVEN
GREATER. DECIMATION OF
BUSINESSES. AND OPPORTUNITIES.
AS WE NOT STOP. AT THE-
BUSINESSES AND LET YOU KNOW
BUSINESS. FOR THEM. GET THE
FEWEST NUMBER THE AB OF
CONTRACTS. THIS IS AN AND LOANS
THAT WE CAN THEN DEPOSIT. AND
THE WITH WOMEN. AND MINORITY.
TO A BASICALLY STABILIZER.
BUSINESSES IF THIS. SO THEN WE
HAVE THE OF YOU TO BE. TO DO
THAT. EVER BILLS LAST I THREE
OR FOUR YEARS. THIS IF YOU'RE A-
YOU MAKE LESS THAN A DOES YEAH
SO I HAVE DOT. AND EVEN THE IF
YOU'RE A MIL CHIEF OF STAFF IN
THE STATE CAPITAL YOU TYPICALLY
MAKE MORE THAN A FEMALE CHIEF
OF STAFF IT TRICKLE DOWN TO
OTHER JOBS. AND PAY EQUITY SO
HERE WE ARE PRESENT DAY IN THE
CITY ASSEMBLYMAN TRY TO CHANGE
THAT THE WOMEN ARE EQUAL TO
MEN. WE'RE STILL FIGHTING THAT
BATTLE WITH INTERESTING KELLY
CHART TOLD ME TO MAKE IT EQUAL
IT WOULD TAKE TEN YEARS. TO
BRING UP THAT PAY SCALE I SAID
B. S. YEAH SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT GOES TO THE VOTE OF THE
VOTERS. THE LATEST THAT
ABSOLUTE THAT'S THE PART THAT'S
TROUBLING WITH PEOPLE IT'S-
IT'S JUST VERY CAUSTIC ON BOTH
SIDES. CHOICE TO VOTE. AND LET
YOUR CHOICE BE HEARD THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT THAT.
SO I'M I'M GONNA SECOND MISS
REYES MOTION. I THANK YOU- SOME
MEMBER COOLEY HAS COME. YEAH I
JUST WANT TO SPEAK TO THIS I
WANT TO START BY SAYING I WANT
TO THANK. I DO THINK THE AUTHOR
HERE I THINK ALL MY COLLEAGUES
REACHED OUT TO ME. I WANT TO
PARTICULARLY THANK MY COLLEAGUE
IS NOT OF THE ROOM REGGIE JONES
SAWYER. WHO OVER SPENDING YEARS
REGGIE JONES SAWYER HAS HAD
EXCELLENT SELECT COMMITTEES.
FOCUSED UPON DISADVANTAGED
YOUTH AND THEIR OPPORTUNITIES.
REGGIE HAS ALWAYS INCLUDED ME
THOSE ARE SELECT COMMITTEES AND
I MADE A POINT IF I'M THERE I'M
THERE I'M THERE FOR THE HEARING
I LISTENED WITNESSES- REGGIE
JONES SAWYER CALLED ME ON THIS
ISSUE. THE MOST RECENT WERE
TOGETHER ON THE- ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON END IN THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE. AND
I ACTUALLY HAVE. THE FOLIO.
THAT I GOT FROM REGGIE JONES
SAWYER. AT THAT HEARING. SO
I'LL JUST SAY REGGIE JONES
SAWYER HAS DONE A GOOD JOB OF
REACHING OUT TO ME OVER YEARS.
TO KIND OF BRING ME ALONG. AND
SO I WANT TO GIVE REGGIE A
SHOUT OUT. I APPRECIATE HIS
AVERAGE SO MANY REACH OUT TO ME.
AND SO I WILL BE AN AYE TODAY
BUT I FOR ONE SPEAK TO SHARE
WHY I'M AN LA. I'VE I'VE KIND
OF GONE THROUGH A LITTLE BIT OF
AN EVOLUTION ON THIS. AND I
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE OF.
HOLDEN. AND I TOLD CHRIS. YOU
KNOW CHRIS I WAS HERE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WHEN WE WERE DEBATING.
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN BUT
BECAUSE PROP THIRTEEN. AND WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW ARE WE
GOING TO PROVIDE TAX RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIANS AND WHAT I SAW
REPEATEDLY IN THE ASSEMBLY BACK
IN THOSE DAYS I MENTION THIS
BECAUSE HIS DAD THEY TOLD WAS
IN THE SENATE AND THAT ERROR HE
WAS A PARTICIPANT IN THIS
DEBATE. WASN'T THERE A SORT OF
A DIVIDE IN THE ASSEMBLY AND-
AND SOME WANTED TO GIVE TAX
RELIEF IN A PRO RATTLE HUESO
EQUAL ALL. SOMEONE OR SOMETHING
THAT WAS MORE TARGETED. THEY
ENDED UP PASSES AT THE MORE
TARGET ENDED UP NOT WORKING OUT
THE VOTERS REJECTED IT. AND IT
IS STUCK WITH ME THAT WE
DEFINITIONS TO SHE DID ACT IN A
WAY ON BEHALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. BUT THAT WAS A
DIFFERENT ISSUE A DIFFERENT
TIME- I DO THINK RIGHT NOW WE
ARE IN A TIME OF GREAT ECONOMIC
TURMOIL. THIRTY THREE MILLION
AMERICANS OUT OF WORK. WE NEED
TO HAVE A PLAN TO START
RESPONDED TO THAT ALL OF US
COME FROM THE STATE'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO CITIES ARE CITIES
HAVE LOST TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE. IN
THE LAST TWO MONTHS. THIS IS
GONNA AFFECT QUALITY OF LIFE IN
OUR HOMES. I THINK WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE THIS YEAR IS
DONE. NEED TO GRAPPLE WITH THE
FACT THAT IT'S LIKE CANCER
TREATMENT. TRONG MEDICINE WHICH
DEALS WITH CANCER CAN SOMETIMES
HAVE OTHER EFFECTS THAT NEED
REMEDIATION. SO I SORT OF FEEL
THIS TIME OF DOWNTURN. THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS LOOK ACROSS A
BROAD ECONOMY IS A ONE OF THE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO. TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLE. BUT WE HAVE TIME TO DO
THAT I THINK WAS TRYING TO GET
A FOCUS ON THAT- MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
CIRCULATED A LETTER ON CITIES
JUST RECENTLY I HAVE AN OP ED
BEFORE THE BE ALREADY FROM LAST
WEEK. THIS TOPIC. I DO THINK WE
ANALYSTS TO JUDY TO FOCUS ON
WHAT DO WE DO FOR THE ENTIRETY
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT THIS MEASURE
FOLKS ARE VERY SPECIFIC PROBLEM
OF HOW DO WE GIVE HOPE. TO
FOLKS WHO HAVEN'T HAD. THE AND
OF MY COLLEAGUE- MISTER VOEPEL
THE VICE CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE
YOU YOU MENTIONED SORT OF THE
FAITH GROUPS SO I'VE GOT TO TWO
IDEAS A TOSSED OUT THROUGH FOR
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ONE IS OUT
OF THE BOOK OF GALATIANS
CHAPTER SIX VERSE TO SIX AND
NINE SAYS DO NOT GROW WEARY IN
WELL DOING. THEREFORE AS WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITY LET US DO GOOD
TO ALL PEOPLE. I SORT OF THINK
THERE'S DEFINITELY AN ETHIC
THAT WE OUGHT TO BE AS
LAWMAKERS FOLKS AT HOW DO WE DO
GOOD FOR ALL PEOPLE. LET'S NOT
GROW WEARY IN WELL DOING. ANY
OTHER ONE THAT CAME TO MIND
ACTUALLY REFLECTED UPON THIS.
IS THE FUNNY LITTLE BOOK AN ILL
TEST OF THE BOOK OF JONAH. JOHN
WHO SENT ON A MISSION TO GO
TELL SOME PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE JUDGED. HE DOESN'T
EVENTUALLY AFTER A LOT OF.
ADVENTURE MARITIME ADVENTURE I
SAY AS I LOOK AND- THERE'S NO
VOEPEL OVER THERE. BUT AT THE
VERY END HE CERTAIN OUTSIDE THE
CITY. AND HE'S UNHAPPY BECAUSE
IT DOES NOT GENERALLY
COMPASSION. AND A PLANT GROWS
UP. SHELTERS HIM FROM THE HEAT
THEN THE PLANT DIES WHAT YOU
REALLY SEE IS THIS BOOK IS
ABOUT HOW DO YOU GROW
COMPASSION. AND THE PUNCH LINE
OF THE BOOK OF JONAH SOMETIMES
WE ARE MORE COMPASSIONATE.
WE'VE ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE SOME
HARDSHIP OURSELVES. JOHN IS ALL
ABOUT HOW JOHN HAD AN ATTITUDE
CHANGE HAVING HAD A GOOD THING
THE KIND OF DRIFTED AWAY. SO I
DEFINITELY FEEL THIS IS ALL
ABOUT TAKING THIS. QUARTER
CENTURY ISSUE SENATE BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN A TIME
WHEN ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
FACING GREAT TRAVAIL. SO ON A
DIFFERENT TYPE AWAY NOT A
THEORETICAL WAY THEY SORT OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT. WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE WHEN HOPE SEEMS LOST. WHEN
TURMOIL SEEMS LOOMING AND YOU
DON'T QUITE KNOW WHERE IT'S
GOING TO GO. AND I THINK IT IS
INCUMBENT ON US TO PRESENT THIS
TO THEM IS THAT QUESTION. TOO
CHALLENGING TO FIND COMPASSION
THEIR HEARTS BUT ALSO FOR US IS
LAWMAKERS TO AND NOW ONLY
DURING THE FALL DASH OURSELVES
WHAT DO WE DO FOR ALL OTHER
CALIFORNIANS. SO THAT WE ARE
MAKING. PROGRESS HELPING THE
CITIES TO DELIVER QUALITY OF
LIFE. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE FLORA JOBS WHO LOST
HER HEALTH CARE IN A TIME OF
COVERT. CAN WE HELP THEM WITH
PRE PAYS ON THEIR COBRA
COVERAGE. THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
THINGS WE CAN DO TO TOUCH OPEN
NEXT FEW MONTHS ACTUALLY FEEL
IF WE BELIEVE IN THIS ISSUE.
AFTER CHORUS ENTRIES RIGHT WE
NEED TO JUMP ON OPPORTUNITIES
TO DO GOOD TO ALL. USE THE
TOOLS ARE TOOL KIT AND- TO A
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA SO I THINK
YOU IS WEBER FOR YOUR
PERSISTENT ADVOCACY IN THIS
AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION HERE AND I TO
APPRECIATE THE- WITNESSES
REFERRED FROM ON BOTH SIDES.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS IS
SEEN ON A SOME MORE LIKE TO
CLOSE- JUST REALLY WANT THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON
AND STUFF ARE WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AS WE
PUSH ACA FORWARD THAT WOULD
ALLOW THIS TO GO TO THE VOTERS
TO HOPEFULLY OVERTURN AN
OUTDATED ADEQUATE LAW- THAT IS
A POTENTIAL POLICY MAKER FOR
DRESSING CRITICAL NEEDS AND
STRIP CALIFORNIA CRITICAL TO.
THE FIGHT DISCRIMINATION HELP
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES HIT HARDEST BY THE
CRITICAL CRISIS THAT WE FACE AS
WELL AS THE OTHER ISSUES IN OUR
SOCIETY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AYE VOTE TO BASICALLY MOVE THIS
FORWARD SO WE CAN EVENTUALLY
TAKE IT TO THE VOTERS AND HAVE
THEM DETERMINE THE NIGHT AFTER
THE TWENTY FORTY YEARS THEY
WANT. THANK YOU. WITH AS A
COMMITTEE TO WITH CAN. EMPIRE
UPON EMPLOYEES I SEE NO REASON
WHY THIS LEGISLATION WOULD DO
ANYTHING BUT FOR THE GOALS OF
CREATING. A WORK FORCE THAT'S
MORE REFLECTIVE OF TODAY'S
CALIFORNIA. ULTIMATELY THIS
QUESTION SHOULD BE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS TO ANSWER.
AFTER OVER TWENTY YEARS I THINK
IT'S FOR ASK VOTERS CONSIDERS
IMPORTANT QUESTION AGAIN
WITHOUT THAT ALSO BE SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE. AND WITHOUT MUCH
SECRETARY LIKE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ON ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHATEVER.
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL HI COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER HI
FONG. FONG NOTE O'DONNELL
RAIDERS RAIDERS I. THANK YOU.
SIX WITH THAT SAID MEASURES UP
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN WITH
THAT SAID WE WANT TO FIVE
NUMBER EIGHT. AB TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN O'DONNELL. THE
SERGEANTS CAN YOU TRY TO REACH
IS OFFICE IF HE'S AVAILABLE
HE'S UP NEXT. OKAY AS WERE
WAITING WANT TO GO AHEAD AND GO
BACK TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THING IT'S ON CALL IN THE
MISSION MEMBERS A SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MOTIONS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX TO ZERO COOLEY. COOLEY AYE.
WITH THAT SAID THAT MEASURES
OUT.
YEAH WOULD YOU PLEASE
OTHERS TO KNOW YOUR YOUR ONE
FIVE WHICH ONE- TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN YEARS. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. TWENTY NINETEEN YES AND
THEN TWENTY NINE. FOR NO NO YES
CONSENT TO SHELBY TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN AS A.
TWENTY TWO AB T.
TO NINETEEN YES. ARE YOU READY
TO ORDER OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
pPRESENT AB TWENTY TWO NINETEEN
WHICH WILL ALLOW CAL STIRS TO
OFFER ITS MEMBERS BOTH
TRADITIONAL AND ROTH ROTH IRA.
ROTH INDIVIDUAL RETIREMENT
ACCOUNTS BETTER KNOWN AS IRIS.
PAID LESS THAN THAN THAN THEY
CAN OFTEN MAKE IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR LACKING SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS
DEPEND ON COMPREHENSIVE
RETIREMENT PLANNING. TO SUPPORT
THEM AFTER THE END AT THE END
OF THEIR CAREERS AFTER THEIR
CAREER. AS PART OF THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING OUR
TEACHERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
DEFINED BENEFIT PROGRAM
PROVIDES TEACHERS. A BASELINE
INCOME THROUGHOUT THEIR
RETIREMENT. HOWEVER THE
INDIVIDUAL FINANCIAL NEEDS A
RETIRED TEACHERS CAN VERY
DRAMATICALLY. FACTORS SUCH AS
EXPENSIVE HEALTH CONDITIONS
INCOME AND INVESTMENTS HAVE
SPOUSES AND OUTSIDE EMPLOYMENT
PRIOR TO TEACHING CAN ALL
AFFECTED TEACHERS INDIVIDUAL
RETIREMENT NEEDS. TO ENSURE ITS
MEMBERS HAVE THE RETIREMENT
OPTION THEY NEED CAL STIRS
OFFERS A NUMBER OF PRODUCTS
THROUGH THEIR PENSION TO
PROGRAM. THESE OFFERS THESE
OFFERINGS INCLUDE FOUR THREE B.
AND FOUR FIFTY SEVEN BE PLANS
AS WELL AS ROTH IRAS TO ROLL
OVER INVESTMENTS FROM EXISTING
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS. THESE
PLANS COVER A NUMBER OF
INVESTMENT OPTIONS THERE ARE
STILL GAPS IN THE TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS CAL STIRS CAN
PROVIDE. ROLL OVER AND
INVESTMENT ACCOUNT OF A SPOUSE
COMMON WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR
IRA IS IMPOSSIBLE WITH THE
CURRENT PLANS OFFERED BY CAL
STIRS ADDITIONALLY END OF THE
YEAR CONTRIBUTIONS OFTEN MADE
FOR TAX PURPOSES ON PRIVATE
SECTOR IRIS ARE IMPOSSIBLE WITH
CAL STIRS CURRENT OFFERINGS. TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS
AND THEIR SPOUSES HAVE EASY AND
DIRECT ACCESS TO THE BEST
RETIREMENT OPTIONS CAL STIRS
MUST EXPAND THEIR OFFERINGS. AB
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN DOES THIS
BY AUTHORIZING CAL STIRS TO
OFFER TRADITIONAL AND ROTH IRAS
TO ALL ITS MEMBERS WITH FULL
ROLLOVER CAPABILITIES FOR THEM.
AND THEIR SPOUSES. THIS WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS TO
PREPARE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
RETIREMENT NEEDS. THROUGH THE
ENTERED THROUGH AN ENTITY THEY
ALREADY- TRUST I KNOW WE HAVE A
WITNESS HERE- ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL HERE- IN I'M GOOD AT IT
JOINING ME ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY. IS JOCELYN MARKING HIS
WEIGHT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT
SYSTEM MISTER CHAIR. YES
JOHNSON ARE YOU THERE-
AVAILABLE VIA PHONE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TWENTY THREE POINT
FOUR MARTINEZ PLAYED WITH THE
CAL. CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AS A FAMILY
MEMBER O'DONNELL FAT AB TWENTY
TWO NINETEEN FURTHERS
CHARACTERS MISSION OF SECURING
THE FINANCIAL FUTURE THEY NEED
TO TRUST THE CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATORS. COUNTERS OFFERS HI
THE TIME WITH A DEFINED BENEFIT
CASH BALANCE INVOLUNTARY
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLANS AS
YOU HEARD WE OFFER FOUR OH
THREE B. AND FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
PLANS THE COURT FINDS AN EASY
CHOICE PORTFOLIO. ALL WITH LOW
COST BE STRUCTURES AND NO
COMMISSION OR SURRENDER CHARGES
AND EVEN WITH THESE OPTIONS WE
STILL HAVE MEMBERS ASKING US
ABOUT OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE
OF ALL OF RETIRED. AB TWO TEAM
WOULD ALLOW CALTRAIN TO ADD AS
AN OP YOUR TO ROB IRA FOR
DIRECT COUNTRY. TRANSACTION NOT
PAYROLL DEDUCTION INTERNATIONAL
IRIS FOR ROLLOVERS BEATING
DIRECTLY CAN I RELAX WORKING TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
VEHICLE THAT CAN MATCH THE
TACTICAL BUT THEN INDIVIDUAL
WITH EITHER PRE TAX
CONTRIBUTIONS TO REDUCE TAXABLE
INCOME. OR POST TAX
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT CAN GROW TAX
FREE INTO RETIREMENT. ROLLING
OVER AT THE END OF A CAREER
ALLOWED RETIREES WORK DIRECTLY
WITH ONE ENTITY INSTEAD OF WITH
THE FORMER EMPLOYERS THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR WHICH CAN
COME WITH EXTRA WAIT TIMES AND
ADDITIONAL CHARGES. AND TO
PROVIDE A HOLISTIC APPROACH AS
WITH OUR DEFINED BENEFIT AND
CASH BALANCE PLANS. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO ALLOW ME TO
CONTRIBUTE. WITH THAT AFTER I
BUILT ON AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THAT
SAID WE DO HAVE- LATE
OPPOSITION THE CAYMAN WILL BE
ALLOWING A ONE PERSON. TO COME
FORWARD STATE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND GIVE ONE
MINUTE. TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH THERE CHIRLA OF NOT MAYBE
JUST A- BUT THAT THERE IS A NOT
SO GO AHEAD. NUMBER. YEAH
BECAUSE NORMALLY FOR WORKLOAD
THE BILL AND TOM FEDERAL
BECAUSE OF THE- RIGHT NOW
THIRDS OFFERED AND FOR YOUR
SPONSORED SUPPLEMENTAL PLANS
BECAUSE THERE ARE MONEY AND
FUNDED BY PREFERRED CONFERENCE
FEATURES AND THIS IS HOW
EXPANDS INTO. AND I'M A PLAN
NOT ONLY GOOD FEATURE BUT
RETIRED FIGURES AND FILED THREE
WE DON'T REALLY THE NEXT DAY
THE FUTURE ONE AFTER DOING
ANYTHING SAVINGS ALLOW
BROKERAGE BUT I'M THAT'S
A GOOD FOR COMP AND IS NOT
ENOUGH MENTAL RECKLESS REALLY
CONCERNING PROBLEM IS THERE'S A
REAL PRETTY FOR CONFUSION THAT
HIGH. TO TEACHERS ARGUABLY
EVERY EVERY DOLLAR PUT INTO A
AS OPPOSED TO A FOR A THREE OF
FOR JUST PLAN PUTS THE TEACHER
WORK FOR POSITION AND FURTHER
FROM READ. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
FOR THREE AND FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
PLANTS OF MUCH HIGHER- LEVEL
YOU CAN COULD THAT MUCH CATCH
UP WITH. YOU CAN TAKE OUT THE
LOWER A LOWER POINT THEY HAVE
HARD AND PERM WHICH I WAS STILL
HAVE THEY DON'T HAVE HIM LEAVE
FOR EARLY. SO THAT BE VERY AND
MIXING THE TWO THINK IT A
POTENTIAL FOR HARM ALL IF A-
ENDS UP WITH BOTH PLAN AND X.
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY'RE
GONNA PAY A PROPELLED THE A TO
THE IRS FOR. DISCREET DEDUCTING
THAT WHAT'S IT MIGHT NOT BE
OVER THERE GOT FOR THOSE
REASONS- OPPOSED TO THE BILL-
WE'VE TALKED TO THE AUTHOR WE
LOOK FORWARD TO. CONTINUING TO
TALK TO HIM ABOUT IT THANK.
THANK YOU. AND THAT SAID GO ON
TO THE NON MAIN WHAT OR TO HAVE
SOMEONE UPS ARE WE HAVE
SOMEBODY ELSE. CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GEORGE MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN TIME ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL. THANK YOU
AND NOW WITH THAT SAID WE CAN
GO ON TO THE NON ME WITNESSES
WHO WANT TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
ALSO IF YOU'RE CALLING VIA
PHONE REMINDER MEET YOUR PHONE
ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. WITH
THAT SAID WE GOT IN PERSON. I
THINK WE HAD ONE ALREADY AND
WITH THAT WOULD GO TO VIDEO.
ANYBODY ON VIDEO WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION FOR
OR AGAINST AB TWO TWO ONE NINE.
VIA VIDEO. SEE NINE VIA VIDEO
ABOUT VIA PHONE ANYBODY VIA
PHONE WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
POSITION ON AB TWENTY TWO ONE
NINE. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL IN Q.
AND AS A REMINDER YOU MAY PRESS
ONE MEN'S ERROL ALTHOUGH FIRST
THE LINE OF. FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE FOUR FIVE THREE. OKAY
READY WELL YEAH. WELL YES STATE
YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATION OF
POSITION MY NAME'S ACTING BY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. OF THE DIFFERENT BILL OUR
OUR HERE ON BILL AB TWENTY TWO
ONE NINE. O'DONNELL ANYBODY ON
THEIR NEXT. THANK YOU AND IF
YOUR POSITION IS NOT ON THIS
CURRENT BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO TO REMOVE YOURSELF WILL GO
TO LINE FOR FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOUR FIVE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN DID YOU HAVE A
POSITION YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE.
OUR POLITICAL ALSO ABOUT EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE SO IT'S NOT TOO LATE
TO. GET THAT THING NOW THIS IS
AB TWO TWO ONE NINE NEXT. LINE
SIXTY FOUR AIRLINERS OPEN. IT
HAPPENED IN SEPTEMBER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND EDUCATORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR COMMENT OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
WE DO HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. IT
WILL BE JUST A MOMENT BEFORE WE
CAN WITH OUR. THE LINE FOR
SIXTY HAVE YOU GIVEN YOUR
POSITION. LAW YES THANK YOU.
NEXT. YOU HAVE PROGRESSED A
LITTLE FASTER THAN THAN WE CAN
PROCESS AND BE JUST A MOMENT MY
APOLOGIES. I'M FOR SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE GOLDEN
ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES INSTRUCTS
APART. THANK YOU FOR COMING
NEXT SPEAKER. JUST. IS COMING
ONE MOMENT.
FIND FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE FOUR SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SHOULD NOT POWERS WITH THE IS
A- POSITION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR COMING NEXT QUESTION NEXT
BIGGER. TWO REMAINING ONE
MOMENT.
FIND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR FOUR FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER BAKER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
COMING NEXT BIGGER. WE HAVE ONE
FINAL SPEAKER AND Q. IT JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. LOOKING FOR ALL
OR DID YOU HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS AGENDA ITEM. HELLO EITHER.
THERE IS NO RESPONSE ON THE
LINE EARLIER OKAY AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO FURTHER LINE THAN Q.
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO VOEPEL. JUST THE JUST A
QUICK COMMENT I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT MR NOR WOULD-
SAID ON BEHALF OF THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY. THERE'S ANOTHER
ASPECT HERE OTHER THAN- OF
GOVERNMENT. ORGANIZATION
COMPETING WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IN BASICALLY
SUPPLEMENTAL NOT BASIC.
PENSIONS BUT SUPPLEMENTAL AYE
ARRAYS AND ALSO I REMIND
EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE THAT
DUE TO THE COVE IT NINETEEN. WE
ARE EXPERIENCING THE ECONOMIC
SHUT DOWN AND TRY TO RESTART
WHICH IS GONNA BE A HAT TRICK I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. BUT HERE
EARLY. IT'S VERY STRANGE TO ME
IF YOU CAN DANCE THE TIME LINE
DOWN WE ARE ACTING IN OUR
INVESTMENT AREAS VERY MUCH LIKE
THE GREAT DEPRESSION OF
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE. WE ENDED
UP WITH THE INITIAL CRASH WHICH
WE'VE JUST COMPLETED AND THEN A
PARTIAL OF KINDA LIKE A FAKE
RECOVERY I HATE TO USE THE WORD
FAKE HERE TRUST ME. AND THEN.
IT RATCHETED DOWN IT'S ALMOST
LIKE AN AIRCRAFT THAT HAS
ENGINE FAILURE. THE INVESTMENTS
THE STOCK MARKET DERIVATIVES
ALL OF IT. AB T. EVERYTHING IS
DOWNWARD AND THEN YOU HAVE LIKE
THE PILOTS TRYING TO PULL UP
AND YOU GO DOWN A DID. AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS CAPITALIST SUCKED IN
AIR AND WHERE I'M GOING WITH
THIS. IS STIRS EMPERORS HAVE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS WITH THEIR
FUNDIE. AND AS THE TAX BASE
EVAPORATES. THAT MEANS THE
CITIES AND ALL THE PARTICIPANTS
OF HERS. ARE YOU GOING TO BE IN
DEEP TROUBLE. ASSEMBLY
FINANCING THE WHOLE YSTEM
WITHOUT A STOCK MARKET CRASH
INTO ECONOMIC CONTRACTION
MISTER CHAIR. WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT IT'S NOW IT'S OUTSIDE
THE PENSIONS THIS BILL SPEAKS
TO EFFORTS OUTSIDE THE PENSION
SYSTEM I THINK THIS ANSWER
STANDARDS GOING EVERY AS A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE JUST
ONE ORDER I THINK HE'S SPEAKING
TO SOMETHING THAT'S NOT REALLY.
IT DOESN'T COMPORT WITH A BILL.
GREGORY JUST STICK TO THE
MERITS OF THE BILL QUESTION
WHERE I'M GOING WITH THIS IS.
FROM STIRS VIEWPOINT. THIS IS
THE WORST POSSIBLE TIMING FOR
THIS BILL I WOULD NOT BE
NECESSARILY AGAINST IT. IN A
COUPLE YEARS WHEN WE SEE WHAT
THE ECONOMY'S GOING TO TURN OUT
TO BE AND WHAT ARE FUNDING IS
GOING TO BE BUT STARS HAS
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR PORTFOLIO
ANYWAY. ADDING ON AN IRATE
MAKES NO ECONOMIC SENSE TO ME
RIGHT NOW AND YOU'RE ALSO.
COMPETING ONCE AGAIN WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THAT'S MY POINT.
THANK ANY OTHER CUSTOMER IF I
COULD RESPOND OF THAT CHURCH
REAL QUICK NORTH OKAY WHAT
EXACTLY THE POINT OF EDUCATION
IS VOEPEL BUT I THINK WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS ACTUALLY
CONTEMPLATES. THAT THE PENSION
SYSTEM CAN'T MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALL OF ALL ITS MEMBERS BECAUSE-
YOU'LL GET YOURS ACTUALLY THE
PENSION TEACHERS GET IS.
ACTUALLY NOT A LOT WHEN
COMPARED TO SOME OTHER PENSION
SYSTEMS OUT THERE- SO WHAT
WE'RE ENCOURAGING TEACHERS TO
DO IS PUT MONEY ASIDE. AND
RECOGNIZE THE FACT. THAT
WHETHER PENSION SYSTEM HELL
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED MORE MONEY THAN THE
PENSION SYSTEM IS OBLIGATED TO
GIVE THEM. TO SURVIVE GOING
FORWARD. SO AS A LONGTIME
TEACHER MYSELF NO I STARTED
EARLY ON. YOU KNOW SAVING
OUTSIDE MY PENSION SYSTEM
BECAUSE I RECOGNIZED THAT THAT
PENSION SYSTEM WASN'T. CARRY ME
THROUGH AND I ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT GEE I'M NOT GONNA GET
SOCIAL SECURITY AND I'VE
WORKED. MANY YEARS AND YET
WON'T GET THE BENEFITS OF
SECURITIES ALL THE MONEY THAT
I. PUT INTO STILL SECURITY I
GAVE AWAY BUT I THINK. THE GOAL
HERE IS TO GET TEACHERS TO SAVE
MONEY SO I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
GOAL. NOW SOME OF THE CONCERNS-
WORD. THERE IS SHOULD SHOULD
THE ON THE IRA IRA BUSINESS WE
CAN WE CAN HAVE THAT DEBATE ALL
DAY LONG. BUT THERE WAS A
CONCERN BROUGHT ABOUT CONFUSION
WHICH I THINK IS GOING TO NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED GOING FORWARD.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TEACHERS
THINKING THAT THEY SHOULD DO IS
JUST GOING TO I'M GOING TO GO.
OPEN IRATE WHEN THEY MIGHT NOT
BE AWARE THAT THEY SHOULD
PROBABLY. GO THE FOUR THREE B.
ROUTE FIRST BECAUSE THAT CAPITA
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE IRA CAP.
RIGHT AND ALSO SOME OF THE
OFFERINGS THAT WE IF TO STARS
AS GOING TO GOING TO THE SERENE
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE-
AT THOSE PRODUCTS THEY DO OFFER
OUR COMPETITIVE. WHEN I FIRST
WENT INTO TEACHING BASICALLY
ALL YOU CAN GET WAS AN ANNUITY.
RIGHT AND THAT PROBABLY AT THE
AGE MY WAS THAT PROBABLY WASN'T
THE BEST VEHICLE INVESTMENT
VEHICLE FOR ME AT THAT POINT IN
MY LIFE IT MAY BE IN A GOOD
INVESTMENT VEHICLE FOR PEOPLE
ANOTHER DIFFERENT POINTS TO
LIVE THERE ARE DIFFERENT AND IT
WAS NOW MORE SO THAN WHAT THAN
THEIR THEIR WORK BACK IN BUT
AGAIN I'D SO THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
CONTEMPLATED AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS- SUMMARY AS HAPPENED.
THANK YOU I THINK I WAS NOT A
TEACHER FOR MY HUSBAND WAS AND-
YES TERRACE- RETIREMENT-
PENSION THAT HE RECEIVED I
THINK IS WONDERFUL BUT IT
WASN'T ENOUGH YOU'RE RIGHT
SAVING ON THAT IN ADDITION TO
THAT. IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
WHICH HE DID AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT BUT MY POINT
IS IT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
TO THAT AS WE TRANSITION SHOULD
THIS BILL MAKE ITS WAY OUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT. OUR
TEACHERS WITH THEIR HARD EARNED
MONEY I GIVEN ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO THAT
THEY MAKE THE WISEST DECISIONS
POSSIBLE AND WHATEVER CAN BE
DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS
SOMEHOW INCLUDED IN HERE SO
THAT THEY DO GET WISE COUNSEL.
BECAUSE THIS HARD EARNED MONEY
IS GOING TO HAVE TO SUSTAIN
THEM AS YOU SAY BECAUSE THERE
IS NO SOCIAL SECURITY. LISTEN I
AGREE THE TEACHERS TO BE
EDUCATED AS TO THE DIFFERENCE
BASS THE BASIC DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A FOUR THREE B. AN IRA
RIGHT THEY SHOULD REALLY. YOU
KNOW THE A PARTICIPATING FOR
THREE BE BEFORE THEY
CONTEMPLATE AN IRA- SO I I'M
OPEN TO EDUCATION TUBERCULOUS I
SAID TO MYSELF TO THE YOUNGER
TEACHERS LIKE WALKING THROUGH
ITS A HERE'S HERE'S WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO THIS SO YEAH I NEED
TO OPEN OUR AND ON A NOTE FOUR
THREE B. HERE'S WHAT YOU DO
WITH THAT THAT THAT THAT YOU
CAN GET IT WITHDRAWN FOR YOUR
PAY ROMA ON A MONTHLY BASIS. SO
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO ENCOURAGE
EDUCATION I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
JUST SHOPS IT'S A TOUGH THING
WHEN I TAUGHT HIGH SCHOOL FOR
YEARS RIGHT IRIS MUTUAL FUND
ALL THOSE STOCKS ALL THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS I HOPE IT
CARRIES THROUGH THOSE KIDS
MINDS TODAY I HOPE THEY
REMEMBER IT FROM HIGH SCHOOL
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE THE
FINANCIAL EDUCATION IS A TOUGH
THING TO TEACH BECAUSE YOU GOT
TO GET PEOPLE THAT RIGHT
MOMENT. THAT RIGHT MOMENT- BUT
I FULLY SUPPORT YOUR COMMENTS
IN THE SUMMER COOPER YOUR
QUESTION THAT RIGHT WHAT MOMENT
WHEN THEIR FIRST HIRED
ORIENTATION SO IMPORTANT RIVER
REPRESENTS ALL FOLKS COME IN
AND REALLY TALK ABOUT THE
NUANCES AND WHAT THE BENEFITS
AND DRAWBACKS ARE AND WE'LL SEE
THAT ENOUGH UNLESS
ORGANIZATIONS DAY ONE WHEN THEY
SIGNED UP FOR THEIR BENEFITS
AND SIDE OF THOSE THINGS TO DO
THAT SO THAT'S REALLY. PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE CAP WITH THEM.
WITH THAT SAID IN OTHER COME.
SAY NONE LIKE TO CLOSE AS
ARRIVAL. THANK ARE MERGING WITH
THAT SAID I THIS A GOOD BILL
OUT IT JUST GIVE THEM ANOTHER
OPTION MORE FOR THESE FOLKS AS
A FOR RETIREMENTS SO I DO
RECOMMEND AYE VOTE AND WITH
THAT- MISTER SECRETARY LIKE
CALDERON. THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO TWO ONE NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL.
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ HI
VOEPEL. VOEPEL NO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER I
FONG. FONG NO O'DONNELL. HI
O'DONNELL I RAY AS- READY AS I.
THE MEASURES UP FIVE TO THINK
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT I
THINK WE HAVE- OUR NEXT BILL
HERE IS MISTER COOPER. COOPER
YOU HAVE TO BILLS- AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY THREE IN AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY THREE. ALL RIGHT
SO AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY THREE
WHEN READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSE I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY THREE WHICH WILL
ENCOURAGE GOOD EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER RELATIONS BY GIVEN THE
PARTIES ADDITIONAL TIME TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT BEFORE AN
AGENCY COMPOSER LAST. BEST AND
FINAL OFFER CURRENTLY PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS ASIANS RESOLVE THEIR
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICES CHARGES
AND REPRESENTATION DISPUTES
THROUGH PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS BOARD COMING KNOWN AS
PER. PURPLE BY THE COST
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE FOR
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
ORGANIZATIONS TO RESOLVE LABOR
DISPUTES OUTSIDE OF EXPENSIVE
COURTS. UNDER CURRENT LAW AFTER
MEDIATION FOR PARTIES WITH
GIVEN TEN DAYS TO RESOLVE THE
REMAINING ISSUES THE
CONTROVERSY BEFORE THE AGENCY
COULD IMPOSE OUR LAST BEST
FINAL OFFER. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY THREE SIX TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FIVE DAYS FOR
PARTIES TO MEET DISCUSS PURPOSE
REPORT. AND WORK TOWARDS AN
AGREEMENT. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE FOR FIREFIGHTERS WHO
UNLIKE OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
OR STATUTORY PROHIBITED FROM
STRIKING IT WILL LEAD TO BETTER
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER RELATIONS
DURING CONTRACTUAL DISPUTES.
THANK YOU WITH THAT SAID YOU DO
HAVE A MEGAN. WHO IS ON BE A
VIDEO- AND SUPPORT. MEGAN ARE
YOU THERE VIA VIDEO. HI RICHARD
THIS IS MEGAN I'M ACTUALLY ON
THE PHONE OKAY MY REAL FROM
OKAY GO AHEAD YEAH THREE
MINUTES THANK YOU. THANK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MEGAN
FAVORS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO BE TALKING TO THE MEASURE
VERY BRIEFLY FIREFIGHTERS RELY
ON HER BACK FOURTEENTH A FAIRLY
SUBTLE. THAT SHOULD SECURING
JUST COMPENSATION THEIR
SERVICES PROMOTING A SAFE AND
HEALTHY WORKING ENVIRONMENT.
ENSURING THAT ESTABLISHMENT
I'VE AUTHOR MENTIONS STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIREFIGHTERS
CANNOT STRAIGHT- ONE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING EFFORT OR CONTACTED
THE THREE REGION AND PASS. OUR
MEMBERS DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
OPTION OTHER EMPLOYEES A TO
EXERT CERTAIN PRESSURES.
GRANTING ADDITIONAL PARTY MEET
EFFECT THE FACT FINDER SHIP
WILL JUST AN ENCOURAGING
AMICABLE RELATIONS BETWEEN
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES AND I'M
SURE THAT THERE IS ENOUGH TIME
TO REVIEW AND AFFECT THE FACT.
FINDER'S REPORT SH AND FIND
COMMON GROUND BEFORE CONTRACT
IS OPPOSED. BY THOSE REASONS WE
ARE ASKING FOR YOUR AYE OPPOSED.
TODAY THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU WITH THE SAID THAT ON WHEN
HE LISTED AS A- PRINCIPAL WOULD
WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE NON
MAIN WITNESSES. WHO TO PROVIDE
TEST WITH THAT STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. AND
WE'LL START WITH FOLKS IN
PERSON ANYBODY WHEN PERSON.
REGARDING AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
THREE. SEE NONE IN PERSON
ANYONE IN VIDEO. TO PROVIDEA
POSITION ON AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY THREE BE- VERY VICTIM
VIA VIDEO I'M SORRY. NOW
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ANYBODY VIA
VIDEO AB ONE NOW GO OVER ON TO
THE PHONE LINES AND BE ON THE
PHONE REGARDING THE POSITION ON
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY THREE. IF
YOU HAVE A POSITION YOU'D LIKE
TO SHARE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
IN Q. ON THE PHONES FOR. ANYONE
THERE. NO NO NO COMMENTS FROM
THE PHONE OKAY SO WITH THAT
SAID BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS. OKAY WITH
THAT SAID- SOME RIVER WE HAVE A
MOTION. MOTION BY MISTER COOLEY
SECOND RESTORE IS. FEB SOMEONE
LIKE CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WITH
THAT I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ON
THIS GOOD BILL PROTECT OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS OF
MUSCLES BOND OF SUPPORTING THE
BILL I RECOMMEND AYE VOTE WITH
THAT MISTER SECRETARY CALDERON.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TWO FOUR THREE
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR
THREE THREE BY SIMILAR NUMBER
COOPER. MOTION IS DO PASS A RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL
AYE COOLEY. COOLEY I'VE COOPER
HI. COOPER HI FONG. FONG NOT
VOTING O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I
AREAS. REYES I. DOUBLES UP SIX
SIX OUT SIX ONE SIX SIX ZERO.
BUT THAT'S THE NEXT BILL WE
HAVE A FIRST FILE NUMBER ELEVEN
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES
EVERY DAY CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
SERVANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES FOR
THEIR LIVES IN LINE FOR A GREAT
STATE. WITH ALL THE UNCERTAINTY
IN THE FINANCIAL MARKETS ARE
PENSION SYSTEMS ARE WORKING DO
THEIR PART TO PROTECT THE
PENSIONS OF ALL OF OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS INCLUDING OUR SHERIFFS
POLICE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
FIREFIGHTERS SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE IS
INTENDED TO GIVE OUR PUBLIC
PENSIONS THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
EVERY TOLL POSSIBLE TO INVEST
AND MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S PENSION
FUNDS THIS BILL CREATE A PUBLIC
RECORDS DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE
THAT WILL ALLOW PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEMS LIKE CALPERS TO
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE INVESTMENTS
IN THE PRIVATE LOW MARKET. IN
THE SAME WAY FINANCIAL
INFORMATION IS CONFIDENTIAL BY
YOUR MORTGAGE COMPANY THIS BILL
SETS UP A STRUCTURE TO PROTECT
A BORROWS INFORMATION FOR PITCH
SYSTEM WINS CAPITAL THREE IF IT
KNOWING THAT. THE BILL STRIVE
WHAT I BELIEVE IS A RIGHT BONDS
BETWEEN CONFIDENTIALITY
NECESSARY FOR BORROWERS THE
TRUTH IS YOU'RE FIRED FOR
PUBLIC PENSION SINCE THE SYSTEM.
MY OFFICE WITH THE SPONSOR HAS
WORKED WITH NEWSPAPER
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION ON
AMENDMENTS THAT'LL KEEP THE
NEUTRAL I COMMITTED PREVIOUS
AMENDMENTS IN MY FIRST IN ABOUT
BILL MY FIRST OPPORTUNITY WITH
ME THEY REPRESENT CALPERS AND
YOU'RE RIGHT. WHO IS A SPONSOR
OF THE- WHAT IT SAID WE HAVE
ANDREW WHITE AND DOWN BROWN R.
Y. HEADLESS AS FOLKS IN SUPPORT.
FROM CALPERS INCOME FOR. OKAY
WHEN YOU'RE READY OF ROOM THANK
YOU THIS EVERYONE WITH THE HELP
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM OR THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE COCKPIT
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS AFTER THEY
WERE FROM THE BILL. AND
ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
EXCUSE ME- THE BILL IS THE BEST
BILL'S GOING TO PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATION FOR OUR CALPERS
INVESTMENT TEAM TO MOVE INTO
THE PRIVATE BOND MARKET. WHICH
IS SPECIALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW- THE BILL PROVIDES A CLEAR
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE WHICH IS
ENTIRELY CONSISTENT. WITH THE
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE FOR.
ALTERNATIVE INVESTMENT VEHICLES
AND FOR PUBLIC BANKS WHICH WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR- I'LL KEEP IT
SHORT. THE BILL FOR ANY
QUESTIONS AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ARRIVAL. DANNY THANK
YOU VERY BROWN IS A WITH EITHER
ONE OF US IS GOING TO HAVE TO
HE'S NOT HERE. OKAY WITH THAT
SAID. WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NON
MAIN WITNESSES WHO WANT TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WITH THAT SO
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION WITHOUT TO ANYBODY
ELSE IN PERSON WHO WOULD LIKE
TO STATE THEIR POSITION ON THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE. WILL SWITCH
OVER T VIDEO ANYBODY ON VIDEO
LIKE STATE THE POSITION ON.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE. SEEN NO ONE VIA
VIDEO HOW ABOUT VIA PHONE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE THEIR
POSITION ON AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE IF THERE ARE
OTHERS TO ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
DISTILLING GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR COMING. IS THERE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS. NORTHERN
SPEAKERS IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT SAID BRING
IT BACK UP TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
VOEPEL I HAVE A QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR. I BELIEVE YOU'VE TAKEN
DIFFERENT AMENDMENTS NOW
THERE'S ONE CONCERN HERE THAT
I'M SEEN THAT. THE BILL AS
WRITTEN THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
CALPERS TO REFUSE TO DISCLOSE
WHETHER LOAN IS IN DEFAULT AND
THE AMOUNT OF INTEREST PAYMENTS
BY A BAR WERE. IN THIS IS AN
INTERESTING QUESTION NOT EVEN
AFTER. WHY WOULD THAT BE A
CONCERN IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
THAT BIG OF A DEAL TO ME. I
HAVE MISTER WHAT ANSWER. THE
QUESTION. YEAH BUT I WANNA MAKE
SURE I GET IT STRAIGHT HERE'S
I'M READING IT ON. AS WRITTEN
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW CALPERS TO
REFUSE TO DISCLOSE WHETHER LOAN
IS IN DEFAULT. AND THE AMOUNT
OF INTEREST PAYMENTS MADE BY A
BORROWER. I DON'T EVEN SEE WHY
THAT WOULD BE AN ISSUE WHY NOT
DISCLOSE IT I MEAN SO THAT THE
AMENDMENT REGARDING- DISCLOSING
ANOTHER ANOTHER LOANS IN THE
FALL. THAT'S PART OF THE
PACKAGE SHOULD THAT MISTER
COOPER HAS COMMITTED TO PUT
INTO THE BILL SO THOSE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE IN THAT WILL BE GOOD
TAKING- WOULD MAKE IT THE
SCHOOLS A UPON REQUEST- WHETHER
OR NOT ALONE IS IN THE FALL-
AND THEN WITH THAT. WE TURN
OVER. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THE CENTER. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS TWENTY MEMBERS. SEEN
NONE- WOULD YOU GO I LIKE TO
CLOSE SOME REMEMBER
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
WITH THAT SAID- THANK YOU
SUMMER COOPER GIVEN CALPERS
CHANGES TO HIS INVESTMENT
STRATEGY DURING THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND BECAUSE OF THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT.
THIS BILL IS A POINT HELP
CALPERS BE MORE FLEXIBLE AND
COMPETITIVE WITH THAT SAID
APPRECIATE YOU WORK WITH ALL
INSTEAD PARTY'S AND BALANCE
POLITICS ORDER PENSION FUND
INVESTMENT STRATEGIES ALSO HAVE
IRAQ WITH THIS. AND MISTER
SECRETARY CAN KALRA BUT DO WE
GET A MOTION AND SECOND OKAY
MOTION SECOND. WITHOUT A SECTOR
COLOR- OKAY WE'RE- WE NEED
ABOUT WOULD HAVE EMOTIONS I
SOME MORE BY MISTER RARE SECOND
BY MISTER COOLEY WITH THAT
MISTER SECRETARY CALDERON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR SEVEN
THREE BY SYMBOL NUMBER COOPER
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL I WILL
TELL AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER AND I COOPER AYE FONG
FONG AYE O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL
AYE RADIUS RAY AS I. THAT
MEASURE OUT SEVEN ZERO. JUST
ONE ONE TWO THE CONTROL. YEAH.
LOGO TO. AB MY ARE ABOUT. WHEN
OUR A GO TO AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ
ARCHER WERE NOT PRESENT. THE
CREATURE MEMBERS TEMPERS ANY BE
TWENTY ONE ONE FOR THIS BILL
SIMPLY PROVIDE THE MINIMUM
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS TO NON
PROVISIONAL REPORTS TO WORK FOR
HIGH HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYER
MEDICAL RESIDENTS AND INTERNS
WORKING IN HIGHER EDUCATION ARE
NOT AFFORDED BASIC RIGHTS
INCLUDING DUE PROCESS REGARDING
TERMINATION OF APPOINTMENT OR
DISCIPLINE THAT COULD NEGATIVE
NEGATIVELY AFFECT FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING MINOR THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ACADEMIC OR CLINICAL MATTER.
BECAUSE OF THE PRICES IN HERE
TODAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE MINOR THINGS DON'T GET IN
THE WAY OF OUR FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HIS WORK SPENT MANY YEARS
LEARNING THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE ESPECIALLY WHEN THEIR
NEEDS WEIRD THEY ARE NEEDED SO
MUCH OF THE TIMES LIKE TODAY.
THE TOP OF THE BED TENSE AND
FLYING WITH THE GUY. EFFORTS TO
FASTER THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. APPLYING DEALING
WITH KOBE NINETEEN WITH ME HERE
TODAY OUR REPRESENT FROM S.
YEAH YOU ARE THE MAIN WITNESSES
ON THE BILL ON PHONE AND I
RESPECT AS FOR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WILL GO TO OUR
FIRST WITNESS. WHICH IS ON THE
PHONE GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CALCULATED MEMBERS
SHOCK AFTER THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES- AS THE AUTHOR
MENTION AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
IS A SIMPLE PARITY BILL TO
PROVIDE HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES BUT DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS BEFORE AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW OFFICER REGARDING
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS THAT ARE
UNRELATED TO ACADEMIC AND OR
CLINICAL MATTER. VIRTUALLY ALL
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ENJOY
THE RIGHT- EITHER AS A MATTER
OF STATUTE CASE LAW OR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
OF PARTICULAR CONCERN TO US ARE
THE MEDICAL RESIDENTS AND
INTERNS EMPLOYED BY THE UC
SYSTEM. CURRENTLY DO NOT ENJOY
THESE TECH MINIMUM LABOR
STANDARDS LETTER AS AN INTERN
HAVE A LOT AT STAKE REGARDING
THEIR FINANCIAL AND BEST IN
THEIR CAREER. BOB ARE STILL
STRONG. THE OFTEN WORK TWENTY
FOUR HOUR SHIFTS. AND EIGHTY
ARE WORK WE- AND IF THEY DON'T
FINISH THE RESIDENCY THEY WILL
NOT BECOME LIKE THIS POSITION.
ALL OF THE STRESS IS COMPOUNDED
BY THE CURRENT CODE NINETEEN
CRISIS. ABSENT THIS BILL IN
MEDICAL RESIDENT COULD BE
DISCIPLINED FOR NOT TURNING IN
THEIR PARKING REIMBURSEMENT ON
TIME. FOR MAKING A COMMENT ON
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT FEAR
OVER A LACK OF PP EQUIPMENT.
AND THEY WOULD NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO HAVE THAT DISCIPLINE
REVIEWED BY AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW OFFICER. NOTHING IN THIS
BILL IS RADICAL OR DEPARTURE
FROM CURRENT LAW AND WE SEE NO
REASON TO CONTINUE TO DENY
THESE EMPLOYEES THE SAME BASIC
MINIMUM LABOR STANDARDS. THAT
ARE EXPORTED TO OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. I HAVE ALSO ON THE
PHONE WITH ME OUR ATTORNEYS GOT
CROMMELIN WHO IS AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE ABOUT THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT IS ON THE PHONE. YES
HELLO THIS IS SCOTT CRAMOND
ATTORNEY FRETS YEAH YOU- I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
BUT I HAVE NOTHING TO ADD TO
THE PRESENTATION. THANK YOU.
NINE MAIN IN SUPPORT. HELLO IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM. THE
SIX TO WEIGH IN ON THIS BILL
SEE NO ONE IN THE ROOM THAT
SEEKS TO WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
VIDEO AND THOSE FOR SUPPORT.
EASY EITHER WAY A CAME IN
SUPPORT OROPPOSITION I'M
LEARNING THIS RIGHT NOW I DON'T
HAVE TO THE STORE FOR A COUPLE
HOURS SO. IT'S GOOD PRACTICE
FOR ME OUR TO GO TO THE VIDEO
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO WEIGH IN
ON THIS BILL. THERE'S NO VIDEO
SO NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONE. NEXT AND STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLACE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU.
HI IF YOU DO HAVE A POSITION IN
LECTURE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. IT WILL BE JUST A
MOMENT. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
POSITIONS IN Q. THE FIRST.
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS-
THOMAS ANYTHING HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE U. A. W. TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT TEN AND
FORTY ONE TWENTY THREE. WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THAT WITH THE
LANGUAGE OF A. B. TWO ONE ONE
FOUR BUT WE'RE CONFIDENT WE CAN
WORK WITH THE BILL'S SPONSOR IN
THE OFFICE STAFF TO WORK OUT
LANGUAGE THAT IS MUTUALLY
ACCEPTABLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS ON THE PHONE
MACBOOK. THANK YOU OUTLINED
FOUR EIGHT SIX FOUR EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AT THAT STATION WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ON THE
PHONE. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE ONE
MOMENT. LOCAL TO LINE FOR
EIGHTY FIVE FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE IS
ONE OCULUS BUT THE CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM- WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A POSITION POSADA BELL BUT
AFTER TALKING WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL WERE CONFIDENT THAT
WILL. TO I'VE WHO IN FACT IS
BEING IN BY. THE STATE OF.
PLEASE CONTACT THAT THE PEOPLE
FOR THE WE JUST WANT TO. OUR
CONCERN BUT ALL PUBLIC THAT WE
ARE PEOPLE TO WORK. THANK THANK
YOU OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. NO FURTHER WE A Q. AND
NO FURTHER WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE WILL RING BACK ANY COMMON
FOR MANY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SAYING NO COMMENT FROM IN THE
ANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M THE WISH TO CLOSE. OUR FOR
PREFERABLE DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE BILL THE BILL TO MOVE BY
MR COOLEY SECOND. SECOND OKAY
WE GOT I'M FIRST AND A SECOND-ON THE BILL. AND WE WILL-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE ONE FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
MOTIONS DO PASSING RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ ARE RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL NOTEBOOK VOEPEL NOT
VOTING COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER- COOPER AYE FONG. FONG
NO O'DONNELL HI O'DONNELL AYE
RADIUS REYES HI. THE BILL IS
OUT IT HAS FIVE VOTES FIVE TO
TWO. FIVE TO ONE I'M SORRY FIVE
TO ONE ONE OKAY THANK YOU- WITH
THAT- WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAIRS ARE ONE MORE. OTHERS I
APOLOGIZE IN THIS IS. AB TWO
THREE SIX FIVE BY A MISTER
RODRIGUEZ A. B. TWO THREE FIVE
YOU MAY PROCEED MR RODRIGUEZ
WHEN OUR- THE MOVED AND
SECONDED MOVED AND SECONDED.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
FIVE WHICH DEALS WITH THE
IMMEDIATE MATTER OF CONCERN FOR
RETIREES RETURN TO WORK AFTER
THEY RETIRE LAST YEAR I LEARNED
THAT A NUMBER OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS WHO HIRED. RETIRED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ARE VIOLATING
THE LAW WHEN IT COMES REPORT IN
HOURS WORKED BY RETIRED WORKERS
TO CALPERS WHEN RETIRED WORKER
EXCEEDS NINE HUNDRED SIXTY
HOURS A FISCAL YEAR THEY MUST
BE REINSTATED FROM RETIREMENT.
MUST REPAY MONEY TO CALPERS OR
FACE OTHER HEAVY PENALTIES.
THIS PURPOSE GIVES COPPERSMITH
THIRTY WAY EVERY REINSTATEMENT
TO HELP RETIRED WORKERS IN THE
SITUATION AND IS JUST ONE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM THAT WE
ALL HAVE TO DO ADDRESS IN THE
FUTURE. WITH ME TODAY IS A
REPRESENT A FROM SLU VIA VIDEO
AND REPRESENT OUR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS A BOY'S
SOCIALIZATION ON THE PHONE. TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
BUT THAT RESPECT AS FOR A VOTE.
I THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MAIN
WITNESS IN THE ROOM WHICH-
WHICH IS TO SPEAK TO THE BILL.
SORRY I WAS THE ONLY ONE IN THE
VIDEO ROOM SERVICE I'VE LEFT
SERGEANTS TO MOVE ON YOU'RE
WELCOME HER COME UP HERE AND-
BLESS YOU WITH MY- PERSONAL
PRESENCE HERE. YEAH YEAH US
JEEZ YOU GUYS IF GOING TO THROW
OUR- S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT- OF THE BILL- THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT NEEDS PROBABLY A
MORE LONG TERM LOOK AT IT- IN
TERMS OF WHO'S RESPONSIBLE WHO
TRACKS THE HOURS HOW MEMBERS
GOT INTO THIS SITUATION. BUT IN
THE STOP GAP- TIME IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE BOARD HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO LOOK INTO EACH
INDIVIDUAL SITUATION AND SAY
THE EMPLOYEE DID THIS. OF THEIR
OWN VOLITION OR NOT AND ALLOW
THEM TO CONTROL SOME THESE
PENALTIES- GIANTS TO PRODUCE
CONTEST PRIVACY SCA AS A DETAIL
ON. THE EXTENT TO WHICH IS THE
PROBLEM- PENALTY STATE. IN A
FEW OF YOU RETIRED YOU GOT
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TOO MUCH
MONEY- BY WORKING OVER HOURS
AND YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FINE TUNING AND
PENALTIES WERE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE NOBODY LOSE THEIR- SO FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. GREAT THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS IS ON THE PHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IF IT DIES THE PROFIT
FIFTY CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
LOCATION. FROM SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE AT BY THE
AUTHOR AND WELL DOCUMENTED IN
YOUR ANALYSIS AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU CALPERS.
AFFECT ABILITY TO DETERMINE IF
THE PENALTY IF THE VIOLATION
OF. COMPOUND THE ASPECTS OF THE
PENALTIES FOR THE VIOLATION CAN
RUN INTO THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS WHICH CAN
BE DEVASTATING COREY TIGHTLY ON
A FIXED INCOME. IN ONE CASE ONE
RETIREE AT THE BEEN MENTIONED.
WENT OVER. THE AND ONLY ABOUT
TWELVE AND IT GOT OUT OF THE
PENALTY ADDED TO. FIFTY THE LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES COUPLE LEAVE
BACK TO THE SYSTEM AND THE
QUITE A TO PAY BACK THE TIME
THAT. THE AVERAGE. RETIREE
SEATS ON THE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
BUT MY AFTER ABOUT YEARS SO
THAT'S NOT A LOT. BUT TO BE
CLEAR CALPERS WITH WEEK THE
RIGHT TO PENALIZE ME TIRED
BUTTONS USE OF SYSTEM. AB TRY
THREE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
GOING TO BE THE REALLY GOT CASE
RETIRING AND OTHERS WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN MISTER. MISLED OR
JUST NOT WORK ON LOW BOBBY
THREE AT PARTICULARLY IN THIS
OF CALL THAT NINETY CRACKED IT.
WOULD REALLY HELP ONE MOST ONE
OF POPULAR I'LL BE TIED. WE
HAVE DEDICATED THEIR WORK AT
THE PUBLIC. YES WHEN YOU ARE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE
OTHERS THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE
SUPPORT UP. WE DO HAVE A- FEW
COMMENTS THE FIRST COMMON AS
FROM LINE FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CALL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE YOU MAY PROCEED. WE
CAN GO TO NEXT CLOSE. WELL I
CALLED A THREE EIGHT FIVE. GOT
A DIFFERENT BILL THOUGH
DIFFERENT BILL THANK YOU. ARE
IN THAT OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU LINE EIGHTY SIX EIGHT SIX.
I CAN. CALLER YOU MAY PROCEED
IF. MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION A
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OTHERS ON THE PHONE AND
SUPPORTER OF OPPOSITION. NINE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME. SO GO TO
THE VIDEO IF THERE'S ANYBODY.
THIS WOULD BE THERE IN THE ROOM
RIGHT. IT SOUNDS LIKE NOBODY
WAS THERE BUT EITHER WAY WE
DON'T SEE ANYONE ON THE VIDEO.
THEY SHOWED UP. I AND NO ONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM SEEKS TO
COMMENT ON THIS. SO THAT WE CAN
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
IS A COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT STRESS. I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION FOR DOCTOR IS
THIS BEING APPLIED
RETROACTIVELY THEM TO PROTECT
THOSE. WHO'VE ALREADY EXCEEDED.
APPLICABLE WORKING TO DO THAT
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE BILL'S REMOVED AND IT HAS
BEEN SECONDED BY MISTER COOLEY
I SEE NO FURTHER COMMITTEE
COMMON WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
PERSPECTIVE FOR I WILL. S.
RIVAL SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS. DUE BY HAS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS ON ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO THREE SIX FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ. RIGAS
ARE. RODRIGUEZ I VOEPEL. VOEPEL
AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER-
COOPER AYE FONG. FONG AYE
O'DONNELL HI O'DONNELL AYE RATE
IS REYES HI. THE BILL IS OUT IT
IS. I WAS WAS ABOUT. SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SO CHAIR IS
GONNA COME BACK UP HERE IN THE
TAKE COMMAND.
ABOUT YEAH. YEAH.
A CALL. OKAY WITH THAT WE HAVE-
JUST ONE MORE BILL WE NEED TO
BRING UP THOSE ON CALL. A CA
FIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
HOWEVER. SECRETARY OPEN THE ROW
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FIVE BY SOME A MEMBER
WHATEVER. O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
HI. THAT MEASURE OUT SIX ZERO.
WITH THAT ARE THE ANY OTHER-
MISSING BOTH MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR SECTOR SIX ONE ON
THAT WEBER GRILL- I BELIEVE ALL
THE OTHERS WERE DONE. OKAY
WITHOUT SAID- THIS INSURANCE
IMMEDIATE ON PURCHASE THANK YOU
ARE READY FOR HELP AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU HIS MANAGER THANKS.